What are you doing on the 4th of September? Oh, you're still free? Why? Haven't you heard that me and me? Are all going to be at the South Bank Centre? We have full weekend live shows for you all from your favourite gold hang of podcasts. Hello, all Shep. I'm going to be there with Tom Holland talking about the most scandalous housewives of Regency England.
9月4日你打算做什么？哦，你还没安排？为什么？难道你没听说我和我？我们都要去南岸中心吗？我们为你准备了整个周末的现场演出，来自你最喜欢的播客组合。大家好，我是Shep。我将和汤姆·霍兰德一起在那里讨论摄政时期英格兰最令人震惊的家庭主妇。
And I'm going to be sitting down with the wonderful Anita, Anna, my co-host on the Empire Pod, to talk about the history of modern Iran with the... the absolutely brilliant Ali Ansari. And Dominic and I will be telling a thrilling Victorian adventure on the Friday night to kick things off. And it's not just us. Mary Beard is coming. Stanley Tootie's coming. You really couldn't ask for a better guest list, unless you were on it.
我将与我在Empire播客的联合主持人，出色的安妮塔·阿南娜坐下来，与才华横溢的阿里·安萨里讨论现代伊朗的历史。周五晚上，多米尼克和我将讲述一个惊心动魄的维多利亚时代冒险故事，为活动拉开序幕。而且不仅仅是我们。玛丽·比尔德要来，斯坦利·图齐也要来。你真的找不到比这更好的嘉宾名单了，除非你也在其中。
If you want to join us, head to southbound centre.co.com. For the full line up, buy your ticket now. See you there. See you there. Ulster stands at the crossroads. I believe you know me well enough to appreciate that I am not a a man given to extravagant language. But I must say to you this evening that our conduct over the coming days and weeks will decide our future. What kind of ulster do you want? A happy and
如果你想加入我们，请前往southbankcentre.co.uk。查看完整阵容，现在就买票吧。到时见。到时见。阿尔斯特正处于十字路口。我相信你足够了解我，明白我不是一个喜欢夸夸其谈的人。但我今晚必须对你说，我们在未来几天和几周内的行为将决定我们的未来。你想要什么样的阿尔斯特？一个快乐且
respected province, in good standing with the rest of the United Kingdom, or a place continually torn apart by riots and demonstrations regarded by the rest of Britain as a political outcast. As always, in a democracy, the choice is yours. I will accept whatever your verdict may be. If it is your decision to live up to the words, Ulster is British, which is part of our creed, then my services will be at your disposal to do what I can. But if you want a separate, inward-looking, selfish, and divided Ulster,
受人尊敬的省份，与联合王国其他地区保持良好关系，还是一个不断被骚乱和示威撕裂，被英国其他地区视为政治弃儿的地方？一如既往，在民主国家，选择权在你手中。无论你的裁决是什么，我都会接受。如果你的决定是践行“阿尔斯特是英国的”这一信条，那么我将随时听候你的差遣，尽我所能。但如果你想要一个孤立、内向、自私且分裂的阿尔斯特，
then you must seek for others to lead you along that road, for I cannot and will not do it. So that was the Prime Minister of Northern Ireland and Old Etonian. Terence O'Neill addressing the nation on television on the night of the 9th of December 1968. And I probably didn't adequately convey in that reading the sheer sense of weariness and desperation that led him to make that speech. You were chipper. You were positively chipper. No, he's a military man. and so he knows the importance of preserving a sense of optimism.
那么你必须寻找其他人来引领你走那条路，因为我不能也不会这样做。那是北爱尔兰首相、伊顿公学老校友特伦斯·奥尼尔于1968年12月9日晚在电视上向全国发表的讲话。在那次朗读中，我可能没有充分传达出导致他发表那次演讲的极度疲惫和绝望感。你当时很开朗。你表现得非常开朗。不，他是个军人，所以他知道保持乐观心态的重要性。
But that has a very ironic, a kind of bitterly ironic ring today, doesn't it? Because we know where Ulster is heading. And it is going to lead to a separate inward looking selfish and divided Ulster, I guess, because it's going to lead to breakdown of law and order, sectarian hatred, sectarian killings, triumph of extremism, riots, shootings, bombings, hunger strikes, troops on the streets, at all kinds of, well, troubles
但这在今天听起来有一种非常讽刺，甚至苦涩讽刺的意味，不是吗？因为我们知道阿尔斯特正走向何方。我想，这会导致一个孤立、内向、自私且分裂的阿尔斯特，因为它将导致法律和秩序的崩溃、宗派仇恨、宗派杀戮、极端主义的胜利、骚乱、枪击、爆炸、绝食抗议、军队上街，以及各种各样的，嗯，“动乱”
doesn't really do justice to what's going to happen. No, exactly. And actually probably not even Terrence O'Neill in his darkest moments could have imagined exactly how grim elements of Northern Ireland's future would be. So that speech is the end of 1968. Last time we were talking about really 1965-66,
这个词并不能真正概括即将发生的事情。不，确实如此。实际上，即使是特伦斯·奥尼尔在最黑暗的时刻，可能也无法想象北爱尔兰的未来会有多么严峻。所以那次演讲是在1968年底。上次我们谈论的实际上是1965-66年，
we were talking about the roots of the troubles, the legacy of partition, the border campaign of the IRA, the rhetoric of Ian Paisley. and then we ended with the first UVF killings in the summer, spring and summer of 1966. And today we're really going to turn to 1968 and 1969. So this is when the sectarian tension becomes real street fighting. And when Harold Wilson's government in London takes the fateful decision to send the British army onto the streets of Northern Ireland.
我们谈到了“动乱”的根源、分治的遗产、爱尔兰共和军的边境运动、伊恩·佩斯利的言论。然后我们以1966年春夏之交的首次UVF杀戮结束。今天我们真的要转向1968年和1969年。这就是宗派紧张局势演变成真正的街头斗殴的时候。也是哈罗德·威尔逊的伦敦政府做出将英国军队派往北爱尔兰街头的重大决定的时候。
And that's something that even a few years earlier would have been unthinkable, but for Tom for most of our, the first 20-odd years of our lives was a fact of life. The British Army were in Northern Ireland, and it seemed at one point that they always would be. So, where to start this story? Well, we'll start it in what might seem a very unlikely place. We'll start it in a pebble-dash terrorist council house in the village of Caledon in County Tyrone in June 1968.
这在几年前还是不可想象的，但对于汤姆和我来说，在我们生命的前20多年里，这是一个既定事实。英国军队在北爱尔兰，而且一度看起来他们会永远在那里。那么，从哪里开始这个故事呢？好吧，我们从一个看起来非常不可能的地方开始。我们将从1968年6月泰隆郡卡利登村的一栋鹅卵石外墙的恐怖分子议会住房开始。
Sir Caledon is just inside the border between the Republic of Ireland and Northern Ireland. It was a majority Protestant and it's controlled in 1968 by the Unionist Party. And as we described last time, if you're controlled by the Unionist Party, if you're in a village there or town, then most of the houses, almost all of them are given to Unionist voters, i.e. Protestants. There are more than 250 Catholic families in the area that are on the waiting list for housing. And some of those families have been waiting for as long as a decade. But this particular council house, which is Nine Kinnaird Park, has just been allocated to a 19-year-old woman called Emily Beatty, who is a secretary for a local solicitor who's very big in the unionist party. Emily Beatty is engaged to a member of the reservist be specials, and she is, of course, a Protestant. And to local Catholics, the fact that she's getting this house seems absolutely outrageous.
卡利登就在爱尔兰共和国和北爱尔兰之间的边界内。它以新教徒为主，1968年由统一党控制。正如我们上次所描述的，如果你被统一党控制，如果你住在那里或城镇，那么大多数房子，几乎所有的房子都分配给统一党选民，即新教徒。该地区有超过250个天主教家庭在住房等待名单上。其中一些家庭已经等待了长达十年。但这栋特定的议会住房，即基奈德公园9号，刚刚分配给了一位名叫艾米丽·比蒂的19岁女性，她是当地一位在统一党中很有影响力的律师的秘书。艾米丽·比蒂与一名预备役B特种部队成员订婚，当然，她是一名新教徒。对于当地天主教徒来说，她得到这栋房子的事实看起来绝对令人愤慨。
And one of the people who rejects is the nationalist MP for East Tyrone, who is a young man called Austin Curry. And on the 20th of June, Curry decides he's going to occupy this house in protest. He wants the world to notice. And with two friends, he breaks in to the house using a poker to get in. But they're not there for very long. The local police, the RUC, throw them out a few hours later. And one of the RUC men who throws them out is Emily Beatty's brother who's come armed with a sledgehammer. Nobody is hurt, nobody is killed. It's not a massive story in the grand scheme
其中一个反对的人是东泰隆的民族主义议员，一个叫奥斯汀·柯里的年轻人。6月20日，柯里决定占领这栋房子以示抗议。他想让世界注意到。他和两个朋友用拨火棍闯入了房子。但他们没待多久。当地警察RUC几个小时后就把他们赶了出来。其中一个把他们赶出来的RUC警察是艾米丽·比蒂的兄弟，他带着大锤来了。没有人受伤，没有人被杀。在宏大的计划中，这并不是一个巨大的故事
of things. So why does it matter? Well, we talked last time about just how divisive, how toxic the issue of housing is in Northern Ireland in the 60s, both in itself, but also as a symbol of something bigger. The sense among the Catholic minority that they are second-class citizens, shut out of the top jobs, denied votes and local elections, even denied homes of their own. Now, it has to be said, a lot of working-class Protestants would take a different view of this and we'll come back to them a bit later. And this has been going on for 40 years or so, but Austin Curry, the guy who occupied the house, is typical of a new generation.
所以它为什么重要呢？好吧，我们上次谈到了住房问题在60年代的北爱尔兰是多么具有分裂性和毒性，既是其本身的问题，也是更大问题的象征。天主教少数群体感到他们是二等公民，被排除在顶级工作之外，在地方选举中被剥夺投票权，甚至被剥夺拥有自己的家园。现在，必须说，许多工人阶级新教徒对此会有不同的看法，我们稍后再谈。这种情况已经持续了大约40年，但占领房子的奥斯汀·柯里是新一代的典型代表。
These are people who don't remember the original troubles, because the troubles, the name was used to refer to the earlier conflict. They don't remember the troubles of the 1910s and 1920s. Somebody like Austin Curry, they've got TVs, they've seen the American Civil Rights Movement, they've seen Martin Luther King, marching in Selma and Montgomery, all these places. and they're impatient to see change and they're keen to learn from the American civil rights activists. Example.
这些人不记得最初的“动乱”，因为“动乱”这个名字被用来指代早期的冲突。他们不记得1910年代和1920年代的动乱。像奥斯汀·柯里这样的人，他们有电视，他们看到了美国民权运动，他们看到了马丁·路德·金在塞尔玛和蒙哥马利等地游行。他们渴望看到变革，并热衷于向美国民权活动家学习。榜样。
This is June, 1968, so a month after the events in Paris. Would that be an inspiration as well, the sense that the world can be turned upside down? Yeah, not as much, I would say. It's a civil rights movement. Yeah, it is. I mean, there was a 68 mood, which I do think matters, and there are other people who are perhaps more influenced by Paris 68, but not so much Austin Curry, I would say.
这是1968年6月，也就是巴黎事件发生一个月后。那也会是一种灵感吗，那种世界可以被颠覆的感觉？是的，没那么多，我想说。这是一个民权运动。是的，确实。我的意思是，有一种68年的情绪，我认为这很重要，还有其他人可能更多地受到68年巴黎的影响，但我认为奥斯汀·柯里受到的影响没那么大。
Anyway, so he's an example of this. He's a history graduate from Queens, and he's become the youngest MP at Stormont, but there are others. There's a guy called Jerry Fit. Jerry Fit had been a stoker on a merchant navy ship. He became an Irish Labour politician, and then in 1966 he won a Westminster seat for West Belfast as a Republican Labor candidate. So Republicans are starting to win seats now. At the start of the 60s, you were saying that they didn't have any. They had zero, yes, exactly.
总之，他是这方面的一个例子。他是女王大学的历史系毕业生，并成为斯托蒙特最年轻的议员，但还有其他人。有一个叫杰里·菲特的人。杰里·菲特曾是商船上的司炉。他成为了一名爱尔兰工党政治家，然后在1966年，他作为共和工党候选人赢得了西贝尔法斯特的威斯敏斯特席位。所以共和党人现在开始赢得席位了。在60年代初，你说他们一个都没有。他们是零，是的，完全正确。
But they're starting to get one or two. I think there were two at this point. And then there's a guy called John Hume, later very well known. John Hume came from a working class family in Derry. He got a degree in history in French, like me. He ran the campaign to have Northern Ireland's second university in the second city, Derry. And he was absolutely outraged when the authorities said, no, we're going to put it in a place called Coleraine,
但他们开始得到一两个。我想当时有两个。然后有一个叫约翰·休姆的人，后来非常出名。约翰·休姆来自德里一个工人阶级家庭。他像我一样获得了历史和法语学位。他发起了在第二大城市德里建立北爱尔兰第二所大学的运动。当当局说“不，我们要把它放在一个叫科尔雷恩的地方”时，他感到非常愤怒，
which is a small Protestant town, not in a Catholic city. So all three of these men, Austin Curry, Jerry, and John Hume become associated with this new movement for Catholic civil rights. They want fair electoral boundaries and end to gerrymandering. They want the fair allocation of housing. They want the end of the B specials, these kind of armed reservists, auxiliary is helping the police. And above all, I mean, the thing they say that really resonates,
那是一个小的新教城镇，而不是一个天主教城市。所以这三个人，奥斯汀·柯里、杰里和约翰·休姆，都与这个新的天主教民权运动联系在一起。他们想要公平的选举边界，结束杰利蝾螈（选区划分不公）。他们想要公平分配住房。他们想要结束B特种部队，这些辅助警察的武装预备役。最重要的是，我的意思是，他们说的话真正引起了共鸣，
particularly because of what's been going on in America, they say in local elections we should have one man, one vote. enough of this business of only getting a vote if you're a tenant or a homeowner. It should just be one man, one vote, universal suffrage. So when most people in Britain or America hear about this it seems completely unobjectionable. Why would you disagree with the principle of one man one vote?
特别是因为美国发生的事情，他们说在地方选举中我们应该实行“一人一票”。别再搞那种只有租户或房主才能投票的把戏了。应该就是“一人一票”，普选制。所以当英国或美国的大多数人听到这个消息时，这似乎完全无可非议。你为什么要反对“一人一票”的原则呢？
But actually, we've already met through your amazing powers of impersonation. We have met one person who would find this very objectionable indeed, the Reverend Ian Paisley. He and his supporters would say, this civil rights movement is a Trojan horse. It is an IRA front to bring down the state that we have built here in Northern Ireland and to force us the Protestants of Ulster into a united Ireland.
但实际上，我们已经通过你惊人的模仿能力见过一个人，他确实会觉得这非常令人反感，那就是伊恩·佩斯利牧师。他和他的支持者会说，这场民权运动是特洛伊木马。它是爱尔兰共和军的前线，旨在推翻我们在北爱尔兰建立的国家，并强迫我们这些阿尔斯特的新教徒加入一个统一的爱尔兰。
Now, most people listening to this will say, well obviously he would say that, but that's bigoted and mad and totally wrong. But actually, this is a really, really interesting question and a surprising story. So the main civil rights organisation was called the Northern Ireland Civil Rights Association NICRA and it was founded at the beginning in 1967 and most of its members were middle class Catholic activists and they were genuinely outraged at what they saw
现在，大多数听到这个的人会说，好吧，他当然会这么说，但这很偏执、疯狂且完全错误。但实际上，这是一个非常、非常有趣的问题和一个令人惊讶的故事。所以主要的民权组织被称为北爱尔兰民权协会（NICRA），它成立于1967年初，其成员大多是中产阶级天主教活动家，他们对所看到的
as the legacy of sectarian discrimination. But you know when Ian Paisley and people like him said this is just an IRA front, there was actually a grain of truth in it. Do you remember last time we said the IRA had done their board a campaign and they'd kind of given up on the arms struggle and they'd focused on left-wing politics. Yeah, they'd gone off and become woke.
宗派歧视的遗产感到由衷的愤怒。但你知道，当伊恩·佩斯利和像他这样的人说这只是爱尔兰共和军的前线时，实际上确实有一点道理。你还记得上次我们说爱尔兰共和军已经完成了他们的边境运动，他们已经放弃了武装斗争，专注于左翼政治了吗？是的，他们已经变得“觉醒”了。
They'd become woke, exactly. And as part of this wokeery, they had set up a series, what they called, Wolftonne societies. So these were basically radical Republican talking shops. Men in polo necks and very earnest-looking women would join a wolf-tone society. It's named after a revolutionary from the 1790s. And they would talk about how to bring about. Irish unity, how to smash sectarianism, ideally how to bring down imperialism and capitalism as well. And it would be presumably joined up with other freedom struggles across the world.
他们变得“觉醒”了，完全正确。作为这种“觉醒”的一部分，他们建立了一系列他们所谓的“沃尔夫·托恩协会”。所以这些基本上是激进的共和党谈话俱乐部。穿着高领毛衣的男人和看起来非常认真的女人会加入沃尔夫·托恩协会。它是以1790年代的一位革命者命名的。他们会谈论如何实现爱尔兰统一，如何粉碎宗派主义，理想情况下是如何推翻帝国主义和资本主义。而且它大概会与世界各地的其他自由斗争联系起来。
Of course. The wretched of the earth. Yeah. How can we take inspiration? All of that kind of somebody would bring along a dogged copy of France Fanon and Albert Camus. No question whatsoever. But there would be a hard-faced man in the corner who's no strange to blowing up a post office, that kind of thing. And it was actually from the wolf-ta... own societies that the idea of a big civil rights campaign really took off. And when you look at the first meeting of this NICRA, Northern Ireland's civil rights association, when you look at who was there at the first meeting, yeah, there are a load of people who like civil liberties and are members of like a Labour Party this and a Labour Party that or whatever, but there are
当然。大地上的受苦者。是的。我们如何从中汲取灵感？所有这些，有人会带上一本弗朗茨·法农和阿尔贝·加缪的破旧书。毫无疑问。但角落里会有一个面目冷峻的人，他对炸毁邮局之类的事情并不陌生。实际上，正是从沃尔夫·托恩协会那里，大规模民权运动的想法才真正兴起。当你看看这个NICRA（北爱尔兰民权协会）的第一次会议，当你看看第一次会议上有谁时，是的，有一堆喜欢公民自由的人，他们是工党这个那个的成员，但也有
communists and there are IRA men, including the commander of the IRA's Belfast Brigade. I mean, this isn't just me making this up. There's a brilliant book on all this by Richard English. with a definitive history of the IRA called Armed Struggle. Right, Richard English. Yeah, I know, he's got very unfortunate. He would say that, wouldn't he? I know, mental. He's a Northern Irish historian called Richard English
共产主义者和爱尔兰共和军成员，包括爱尔兰共和军贝尔法斯特旅的指挥官。我的意思是，这不仅仅是我编造的。理查德·英格利什有一本关于这一切的精彩著作，书名是《武装斗争》，是爱尔兰共和军的权威历史。对，理查德·英格利什。是的，我知道，他很不幸。他会那么说的，不是吗？我知道，疯了。他是一位名叫理查德·英格利什的北爱尔兰历史学家，
who writes about the IRA. I mean, Richard Prod. So here's the thing. In some ways, it does kind of start as an IRA front, but it becomes something much bigger. I mean, you mentioned Paris, because it does catch the mood of the mid-60s. It attracts loads of people,
他撰写了关于爱尔兰共和军的文章。我的意思是，理查德·普罗德。所以事情是这样的。在某些方面，它确实有点像爱尔兰共和军的前线，但它变得大得多了。我的意思是，你提到了巴黎，因为它确实捕捉到了60年代中期的情绪。它吸引了大量的人，
especially students who are not really interested in the IRA. They're not interested in overthrowing the state. They're not Marxists. They actually are genuinely interested in housing and in fair voting and all of this kind of stuff. So in that sense, Ian Paisley and people who are talking about the Trojan horse, they're right in one way but wrong in another.
特别是那些对爱尔兰共和军并不真正感兴趣的学生。他们对推翻国家不感兴趣。他们不是马克思主义者。他们实际上是真心关心住房、公平投票以及所有这些事情。所以从这个意义上说，伊恩·佩斯利和那些谈论特洛伊木马的人，他们在某种程度上是对的，但在另一方面是错的。
Isn't that history all the time? Yeah. History is a land of contrast. The civil rights movement might have in some ways started as an IRA front, but it has become something much bigger. and much broader. And actually the real tragedy of the civil rights movement really is its timing. Because as we said, it's modelled on the American Civil Rights Movement.
历史不总是这样吗？是的。历史是一片对比之地。民权运动在某些方面可能始于爱尔兰共和军的前线，但它已经变得大得多，也宽广得多。实际上，民权运动真正的悲剧在于它的时机。因为正如我们所说，它是以美国民权运动为蓝本的。
But the thing about the American Civil Rights Movement is easily forgotten, is that it comes to fruition and it peaks at a point when people in America are extremely well off, including people in the South, which is booming. You know, it's the affluent society, massive economic growth, rising wages, people are very optimistic about the future. It's easier to make changes. against that background than it is when things are bleak. And of course, in Northern Ireland, the civil rights movement is coming to prominence,
但关于美国民权运动，人们容易忘记的一点是，它是在美国人非常富裕的时候取得成果并达到顶峰的，包括南方的人，那里正在蓬勃发展。你知道，那是富裕社会，巨大的经济增长，工资上涨，人们对未来非常乐观。在那种背景下做出改变比在情况黯淡时更容易。当然，在北爱尔兰，民权运动开始崭露头角，
1967, 68, precisely the point when the traditional industries on which Northern Ireland depends are in real trouble, the jobs are drying up. The working class Protestants that probably you do need to persuade are frightened about economic and cultural change. So it's much more difficult. If you've come back from the shipyard, you're worried your job's going to go. when you open the newspaper and you see a load of people are complaining about something, effectively you have to make the concession, it's much harder to do, I would say.
1967、68年，恰恰是北爱尔兰所依赖的传统工业陷入真正困境的时候，工作岗位正在枯竭。你可能确实需要说服的工人阶级新教徒对经济和文化变革感到恐惧。所以这要困难得多。如果你刚从造船厂回来，你担心你的工作会丢。当你打开报纸，看到一堆人在抱怨什么，实际上你必须做出让步，我想说这要困难得多。
And this is one reason why I said we'd come back to this issue about second-class citizens. It's why it's very hard for a lot of unionists to accept the second-class citizen criticism. So there's a great book called Loyalists by Peter Taylor. Peter Taylor, BBC journalist, did three books called Provo's Brits Loyalists, basically oral histories, lots of interviews, looking at the conflict through three different lenses. And this is one on loyalists. It's full of interviews with poor, working-class Protestants,
这就是为什么我说我们要回到关于二等公民的问题。这就是为什么很多统一派很难接受二等公民的批评。所以有一本很棒的书叫《忠诚派》，作者是彼得·泰勒。彼得·泰勒，BBC记者，写了三本书，分别叫《Provo's》、《Brits》、《Loyalists》，基本上是口述历史，有很多采访，通过三个不同的镜头审视冲突。这是关于忠诚派的一本。它充满了对贫穷的工人阶级新教徒的采访，
who are very defensive, indeed, outraged, when they hear about Catholics saying they are second-class citizens. Our housing was the same as our Catholic next-door neighbor, two up, two down, with an outside toilet. It really irks me when I hear about the disadvantages that the Catholics had. Protestantism and unionism in Northern Ireland, it's not a monolith. There are a lot of very poor people who are part of that community. And they feel, you know, when they're told, oh, you are the first class citizens,
当他们听到天主教徒说他们是二等公民时，他们非常防御，甚至感到愤怒。我们的住房和隔壁的天主教邻居一样，两层楼，外面有厕所。当我听到天主教徒所受的不利待遇时，我真的很生气。北爱尔兰的新教和统一主义并不是铁板一块。那个社区里有很多非常贫穷的人。他们觉得，你知道，当他们被告知“哦，你们是头等公民，
you have the whip hand over in your neighbours. They're offended by this because they don't feel that way at all. And so, of course, the tragedy in some ways, the tragic irony of the civil rights movement is that it actually inadvertently, through no fault of their own in many ways, drives people like this into the arms of Ian Paisley and away from the centre ground and away from Terrence O'Neill because there was never any opportunity that they could have signed up with housing activists
你们对邻居拥有支配权”时，他们被冒犯了，因为他们根本没有那种感觉。所以，当然，民权运动的悲剧在某种程度上，悲剧性的讽刺在于，它实际上在无意中，在许多方面并非出于他们的过错，将这样的人推向了伊恩·佩斯利的怀抱，远离了中间地带，远离了特伦斯·奥尼尔，因为他们从来没有任何机会与住房活动家签署协议，
in Protestant community, do you think? Well, they didn't have housing activists in Protestant communities because they were getting housing. But they were kind of houses with no toilets. We get together and improve housing across Northern Ireland. There were organisations like that for you. You could join the Northern Ireland. Labour Party.
你认为在新教社区里有吗？好吧，他们在新教社区里没有住房活动家，因为他们有房子住。但那些房子有点像没有厕所的房子。我们聚在一起改善北爱尔兰的住房。有那样的组织。你可以加入北爱尔兰工党。
And the Northern Ireland Labour Party would say we are open to all people irrespective of a religion and we're fighting for better conditions and rights and whatnot for working class people. That's what we're all about. But it's a less sexy story, isn't it, than one that is about suffering and adventure and fighting and dying to quote, was it, Gusty Spence, all of that kind of thing. That's a story that seems richer and has much more traction and is more emotionally meaningful than one that's just a bit bland and sort of.
北爱尔兰工党会说，我们对所有人开放，不分宗教，我们正在为工人阶级争取更好的条件和权利等等。这就是我们的全部意义。但这不像关于苦难、冒险、战斗和死亡的故事那样性感，引用一下，是古斯蒂·斯彭斯吗，所有这些。那是一个看起来更丰富、更有吸引力、在情感上更有意义的故事，而不是一个有点平淡、某种程度上
of old working class people getting together and fighting for better toilets or something, I would say, better washing machines. Better washing machines. Well, this is the Samba review of history. Anyway, let's get back to Austin Curry and that house in Caledon. You know, asked about Paris, 1968. Of course, it's also the Prague Spring, student protests in America, all of this kind of thing. And when people read about Austin Curry occupying the house, they're like, yes, this is exciting. You know, the revolution is coming to Northern Ireland. Brilliant. And a few weeks after his Caledan protest, Curry goes to a meeting of the civil rights groups. And he says, let's do something bigger. Let's have a march like they have in America.
老工人阶级聚在一起为更好的厕所或类似的东西而战，或者更好的洗衣机。更好的洗衣机。好吧，这就是历史的桑巴评论。总之，让我们回到奥斯汀·柯里和卡利登的那栋房子。你知道，问到1968年的巴黎。当然，这也是布拉格之春、美国的学生抗议等等。当人们读到奥斯汀·柯里占领那栋房子时，他们会说，是的，这太令人兴奋了。你知道，革命正在来到北爱尔兰。太棒了。在他卡利登抗议几周后，柯里去参加了一个民权团体会议。他说，让我们做点更大的事。让我们像在美国那样举行游行。
Martin Luther King would do these marches through Alabama or something. Loads of publicity. Let's have a march of her own. We'll have a march to draw attention to housing discrimination in County Tyrone. And so it is that on the 24th of August, 4,000 people join him in Northern Ireland's first. big civil rights demonstration. They march from the village of Coal Island to Dungannon. And it all goes well. You know, 4,000 people, they're trudging along. They're all happy, singing songs, whatever. But the people who are the more radical side of the movement are very
马丁·路德·金会在阿拉巴马州等地进行这些游行。大量的宣传。让我们举行我们自己的游行。我们将举行一次游行，以引起人们对泰隆郡住房歧视的关注。于是，在8月24日，4000人加入了他在北爱尔兰的第一次大型民权示威。他们从煤岛村游行到邓甘嫩。一切都很顺利。你知道，4000人，他们步履蹒跚。他们都很开心，唱着歌，等等。但那些属于运动中更激进派别的人非常
disappointed. They say, well, come on. The thing about Martin Luther King's marches is they got the publicity because they were attacked, because they ended in violence. If you want to grab people's attention, you actually do need a bit of violence. You need a bit of violence. You need confrontation. You need to expose the sordid reality of the state. So then people will see you as martyrs and they'll see the state for what it really is, which is repressive and cruel and violent and so on. And so they say the next march should be somewhere much more high profile, namely the city of Derry or officially London Derry. So this, as we said last time, Northern Ireland's second city, 6040 Catholic Protestant. Economically Derry is really struggling. One in five men
失望。他们说，好吧，来吧。马丁·路德·金游行的关键在于，他们之所以获得宣传，是因为他们受到了攻击，因为他们以暴力告终。如果你想抓住人们的注意力，你确实需要一点暴力。你需要一点暴力。你需要对抗。你需要揭露这个国家肮脏的现实。这样人们就会把你视为烈士，他们就会看到这个国家的真面目，即压迫、残酷和暴力等等。所以他们说下一次游行应该在更引人注目的地方，即德里市，或者正式名称伦敦德里。所以正如我们上次所说，这是北爱尔兰的第二大城市，60%天主教徒，40%新教徒。在经济上，德里真的很挣扎。五分之一的男人
are out of work. The mood is very bleak, it is very fractious, it is the worst possible place to hold a demonstration. And not just because it's poor, but because it has such a symbolic resonance for the Protestants. Symbolic for both sides. Symbolic for the Catholics, because it's a Catholic majority city, run by Protestants, symbolic for the Protestants, because there was this siege in 1689, and they hold the apprentice boys of Derry March every year to remember it. But if their goal is to get a kind of violent reaction, then they need to annoy Protestants, don't they? Yeah, and this is the place. You know, they want the kind of the equivalent of the bullneck sheriff going in.
失业。情绪非常阴郁，非常易怒，这是举行示威最糟糕的地方。不仅因为它贫穷，还因为它对新教徒有如此强烈的象征意义。对双方都有象征意义。对天主教徒来说是象征性的，因为它是一个天主教占多数的城市，由新教徒管理；对新教徒来说是象征性的，因为1689年发生了那场围城战，他们每年都举行德里学徒男孩游行来纪念它。但如果他们的目标是获得某种暴力反应，那么他们就需要激怒新教徒，不是吗？是的，这就是地方。你知道，他们想要那种类似布尔·康纳警长进去，
Bull Connor. Yeah, all that kind of thing. And smacking up civil rights protesters in America, if they want the same thing, then they have to kind of press Protestant neuralgic areas. Yeah, totally. Totally. And this is what they're doing. Their plan is they will start on the east side of the city across the lower. River Foil. They will cross the Craig Avon Bridge. They'll go into the city centre. They will go through
布尔·康纳。是的，所有这些。在美国殴打民权抗议者，如果他们想要同样的事情，那么他们就必须触碰新教徒的神经痛点。是的，完全正确。完全正确。这就是他们正在做的。他们的计划是，他们将从城市东侧穿过福伊尔河。他们将穿过克雷格阿文大桥。他们将进入市中心。他们将穿过
Protestant areas. They will end inside the city walls, which are of course sacred really to Protestants, where the apprentice boys of Derry have their parade. And they will end near the war memorial in the centre of Derry again, a sacred spot for Protestants. Now, as the Irish historian Tim Pat Coogan, and not everybody's cup of tea, quite nationalist history, but as he rightly says in his book, The Troubles, he says it was as though Hamas were to parade through Jerusalem's holy places and conclude with a rally at the wailing wall. Well, when you put it like that, but it's not quite as bad as that,
新教地区。他们将在城墙内结束，这对新教徒来说当然是神圣的，德里学徒男孩在那里举行游行。他们将在德里市中心的战争纪念碑附近结束，这再次是新教徒的神圣之地。现在，正如爱尔兰历史学家蒂姆·帕特·库根所说，并不是每个人的菜，相当民族主义的历史，但正如他在他的书《动乱》中正确指出的那样，他说这就像哈马斯在耶路撒冷的圣地游行，并以在哭墙的集会结束。好吧，当你这样说的时候，但这并没有那么糟糕，
but it's kind of, it's very provocative. And at Stormont, the hardline home affairs minister, William Craig, who's always keen to bolster his popularity with the sort of more extreme unionists. He does the obvious thing he bans the march, as he's empowered to do. But on the 5th of October, 1968, about 400 people, including Austin Curry and Jerry Fitt, and some, I think there's three British Labour MPs, they turn up at the appointed spot on Duke Street anyway. And when they turn up, they find the street is blocked at both ends by lines of RUC
但这有点，非常挑衅。在斯托蒙特，强硬派内政部长威廉·克雷格，他总是热衷于通过更极端的统一派来巩固自己的人气。他做了显而易见的事情，他禁止了游行，正如他有权做的那样。但在1968年10月5日，大约400人，包括奥斯汀·柯里和杰里·菲特，还有一些，我想有三名英国工党议员，他们还是出现在了杜克街的指定地点。当他们出现时，他们发现街道两端都被RUC的防线封锁了，
policemen who have been ordered to clear the road by force. Now, if you read some accounts, they will say that the Derry IRA had had a meeting beforehand. They are planned for this and they had said, when it kicks off, make sure those MPs are in the front line so they get hit because that will give us the publicity that we want. Well, this is exactly what happens. The RUC, you know, they play the part appointed for them as the bullnicked kind of American sheriff. they pile into the marchers. Some of the marchers managed to get to the bridge, but there they are driven back by a water cannon
警察接到命令要用武力清理道路。现在，如果你读一些报道，他们会说德里爱尔兰共和军事先开过会。他们为此做了计划，他们说，当它开始时，确保那些议员在前线，这样他们就会被打，因为那会给我们想要的宣传。好吧，这正是发生的事情。RUC，你知道，他们扮演了分配给他们的角色，就像布尔·康纳那样的美国警长。他们冲进游行队伍。一些游行者设法到达了桥上，但在那里他们被水炮驱赶，
into a kind of hail of baton blows. 80 or so people are taken to hospital with injuries, and one of them is Jerry Fit. Remember, a Westminster MP, who is beaten, he's dragged away, put in a police van, and taken to the police station. At the police station,
进入了一阵警棍打击中。大约80人因伤被送往医院，其中一人是杰里·菲特。记住，一位威斯敏斯特议员，他被打，被拖走，放进警车，带到警察局。在警察局，
the police say to him, clean yourself up, and he refuses, I wanted the outside world to see the blood flowing strongly down my face. And what is really toxic for Northern Ireland's image is that an Irish TV crew, an RTE crew, had filmed the whole thing.
警察对他说，清理一下自己，他拒绝了，我希望外界看到鲜血顺着我的脸流下来。对北爱尔兰形象真正有毒的是，一个爱尔兰电视摄制组，一个RTE摄制组，拍摄了整个过程。
So the footage of the RUC officer's absolutely leathering fit in the others with their batons and their sticks goes around the world. If you kind of Google it, you can see photos of it. I mean, that is what they wanted, isn't it? I mean, it couldn't be better for them. You're right, from their perspective, it couldn't be better. but I think if you were to pick one moment well there are lots of different moments
所以RUC警官用警棍和棍子猛击菲特和其他人的镜头传遍了世界。如果你谷歌一下，你可以看到它的照片。我的意思是，这就是他们想要的，不是吗？我的意思是，这对他们来说再好不过了。你是对的，从他们的角度来看，再好不过了。但我认为如果你要挑选一个时刻，嗯，有很多不同的时刻，
but this is a contender for one of the moments where the sort of spiral into disaster becomes inevitable because it's followed by days of rioting in Derry in the working class bogside area very heavily Catholic there are young men throwing stones and petrol bombs at the police
但这是一个竞争者，是那种陷入灾难的螺旋变得不可避免的时刻之一，因为它随后在德里工人阶级的博格赛德地区发生了几天的骚乱，那里天主教徒非常多，有年轻人向警察投掷石块和汽油弹，
and then there are kind of copycat riots across Northern Ireland watching all this from Belfast Terence O'Neill knows that he has to do something and five days after he says to his cabinet, he meets his cabinet, he says, I'm going to go to London, I'm going to see Harold Wilson, and I know that Harold Wilson is going to ask me for some pretty big changes.
然后北爱尔兰各地出现了模仿骚乱。从贝尔法斯特观察这一切的特伦斯·奥尼尔知道他必须做点什么。五天后，他对他的内阁说，他会见了他的内阁，他说，我要去伦敦，我要见哈罗德·威尔逊，我知道哈罗德·威尔逊会要求我做出一些相当大的改变。
And O'Neill, I mean, I have to admit, I think O'Neill is hapless, but I feel really sorry for him because I think his instincts are often, you know, admirable. He says to his colleagues, look, we know how this works. Whenever there is trouble, and I quote, the first reaction of our own people is to retreat into old hardline attitudes. He says, come on, let's be honest. Can any of us truthfully say in the confines of this room that the minority has no grievance calling for remedy?
奥尼尔，我的意思是，我必须承认，我认为奥尼尔是倒霉的，但我真的很同情他，因为我认为他的直觉通常是，你知道，令人钦佩的。他对同事们说，看，我们知道这是怎么回事。每当有麻烦时，我引用一下，“我们自己人的第一反应是退回到旧的强硬态度中。”他说，来吧，让我们诚实一点。我们房间里有谁能真诚地说少数群体没有需要补救的冤屈吗？
He says we cannot govern by police power alone. It will be a very hard job to sell concessions to our people, but in this critical moment may this not be our duty. I mean, I think now you read that and you think very, very much. enough. But not all of his ministers agree with him. So I already mentioned the hardline home affairs minister William Craig. William Craig says to him, hold on, you can't go over to London and meet Harold Wilson and sell out and let him and make you introduce reforms. Because if you do that, you will, and I quote, provoke a massive uprising in the loyalist community. I mean, this is the dilemma for Terrence O'Neill.
他说我们不能仅靠警察权力来治理。向我们的人民推销让步将是一项非常艰巨的工作，但在这一关键时刻，这难道不是我们的职责吗？我的意思是，我想现在你读到这些，你会想非常、非常多。足够了。但并非他所有的部长都同意他的观点。所以我已经提到了强硬派内政部长威廉·克雷格。威廉·克雷格对他说，等等，你不能去伦敦见哈罗德·威尔逊并出卖我们，让他让你进行改革。因为如果你这样做，你将，我引用一下，“在忠诚派社区引发大规模起义。”我的意思是，这就是特伦斯·奥尼尔的困境。
Basically, the obvious thing might seem to be to make concessions to the Catholics, but if you do that, you're in danger of losing your base. Now, a very skillful politician might be able to do that, whether he is that man we will find out. He flies off to London, 4th of November, to meet Wilson and his home secretary, friend of the show, Jim Callahan. Now, just for people who haven't listened to our series about Britain in the 70s, Harold Wilson, enthusiast for scouting. Tight shorts, isn't he? Very tight shorts on holiday in the city islands. Loves modernisation, the White Eaters technology. Giving the Beatles MBEs.
基本上，显而易见的事情似乎是向天主教徒做出让步，但如果你这样做，你就有失去基础的危险。现在，一个非常熟练的政治家也许能做到这一点，他是否是那个人，我们将拭目以待。他飞往伦敦，11月4日，去见威尔逊和他的内政大臣，节目的朋友，吉姆·卡拉汉。现在，对于那些没有听过我们关于70年代英国系列节目的人来说，哈罗德·威尔逊，童子军爱好者。紧身短裤，不是吗？在锡利群岛度假时穿着非常紧的短裤。热爱现代化，白色加热技术。给披头士乐队颁发MBE。
Correct. Exactly. Economic growth. He came to power. People thought he might be quite left wing. He became more and more centrist as time went on. He had become prime minister in 1964. Some Labour backbenches, as we said last time, were already complaining a lot about discrimination
正确。完全正确。经济增长。他上台了。人们认为他可能相当左倾。随着时间的推移，他变得越来越中间派。他于1964年成为首相。正如我们上次所说，一些工党后座议员已经在抱怨很多关于歧视
against Catholics in Northern Ireland. But most people in the Labour Party don't really care that much. Harold Wilson certainly doesn't care. He's much more interested in the economy, in the trade unions, in Rhodesia, even in Vietnam. When he read the diaries of his minister, like Tony Benn, Barbara Castle, Richard Crossman, they basically never talk about Northern Ireland at all.
北爱尔兰天主教徒的问题。但工党的大多数人并不真正关心。哈罗德·威尔逊当然也不关心。他更关心经济、工会、罗得西亚，甚至越南。当你读到他的部长们的日记时，比如托尼·本、芭芭拉·卡斯尔、理查德·克罗斯曼，他们基本上根本不谈论北爱尔兰。
It's not the top of their list. I think what listeners will want to know is Marcia on the scene at this point, his domineering secretary who, in the mid-70s, people are plotting to kill. Yeah, there's no plots to kill Marcia at this point. Marcia and Harold, if they had their affair, they've had it. Remember, they slept together a number of times, but it was not satisfactory. Found it disappointing, yeah.
这不是他们的首要任务。我想听众想知道的是玛西娅当时在现场，他那个专横的秘书，在70年代中期，人们密谋要杀她。是的，此时没有密谋杀害玛西娅。玛西娅和哈罗德，如果他们有婚外情，他们已经有了。记住，他们睡过几次，但并不令人满意。觉得很失望，是的。
So she's lurking, but it hasn't all complicated. completely gone mad at this point. It's quite understated. His home secretary is Jim Callahan, friend of the show, Portsmouth, the Royal Navy, very puritanical, big man, a bit of a bully, great San Brookian hero. He's been home secretary since the end of 1967. As we said before, he has an Irish background, hence the name Callahan. His grandfather had moved to England during the famine, but Callahan basically has very little knowledge or interest of Northern Ireland. He wrote a book about it or had a book ghost written for him in the early 1970s about it. I can't remember what was called a problem of Ulster or something like that. And he said that when he arrived at
所以她在潜伏，但此时还没有完全疯掉。这相当低调。他的内政大臣是吉姆·卡拉汉，节目的朋友，朴茨茅斯，皇家海军，非常清教徒，大个子，有点欺凌弱小，伟大的桑布鲁克英雄。他自1967年底以来一直担任内政大臣。正如我们之前所说，他有爱尔兰背景，因此叫卡拉汉。他的祖父在饥荒期间搬到了英国，但卡拉汉基本上对北爱尔兰知之甚少或毫无兴趣。他在1970年代初写了一本关于它的书，或者让人代笔写了一本。我不记得叫什么了，阿尔斯特的问题之类的。他说当他到达
the home office, they gave him a huge sort of briefing document. There's lots of stuff about prisons, race relations, the fire service, the police, and there was nothing in this document about Northern Ireland at all. There isn't at this point a secretary of state for Northern Ireland? No, no, no, no, no. We don't need one because it's being run from Belfast. However, Wilson and Callahan are interested now because there's a lot of fighting. You know, there's been this business in dairy. They can see there's a problem. But at the end of 1968, they've got a problem.
内政部时，他们给了他一份巨大的简报文件。有很多关于监狱、种族关系、消防服务、警察的内容，文件中根本没有关于北爱尔兰的内容。此时没有北爱尔兰事务大臣吗？不，不，不，不，不。我们不需要一个，因为它是从贝尔法斯特管理的。然而，威尔逊和卡拉汉现在感兴趣了，因为有很多战斗。你知道，德里发生了这件事。他们能看出有问题。但在1968年底，他们遇到了一个问题。
They want Terrence O'Neill to fix it. And they're quite hard on him, actually. For people who listen to previous series who think they're sort of all a bit limp, not at all. Howard Wilson said to him, look, you need our money. You can't survive without British money. If you don't start introducing reforms, we'll cut off your money. Callaghan, we have had enough of you stringing us along. He says, we've got a list of changes. We want to see them right away. And O'Neill said to them,
他们想让特伦斯·奥尼尔解决它。而且他们对他相当严厉，实际上。对于那些听过之前系列节目，认为他们有点软弱的人来说，一点也不。哈罗德·威尔逊对他说，看，你需要我们的钱。没有英国的钱你无法生存。如果你不开始进行改革，我们就切断你的钱。卡拉汉，我们受够了你一直拖着我们。他说，我们有一份改变清单。我们想马上看到它们。奥尼尔对他们说，
look, I'm going as far as I can. I'm getting death threats from loyalists. You know, don't push this. I can't. If you push us too far, there'll be a loyalist uprising or whatever. Anyway, he goes back to Belfast and he says to his colleagues, they were very tough, I've got to give them something. And so he unveils this very limited reform package. So limited to reformers and who gets the vote. There's a new system for allocating housing. Some police reform as all of this. And it is your classic case of, if you had offered this in 1963, it would have been a different story, but now it's 1968 and you please nobody at all. The civil rights activists say, come on, this, like you've got to dismantle the whole discriminatory
看，我正在尽我所能。我收到了来自忠诚派的死亡威胁。你知道，别逼得太紧。我不能。如果你逼得太紧，就会有忠诚派起义之类的。总之，他回到贝尔法斯特，对同事们说，他们非常强硬，我必须给他们一些东西。于是他公布了这个非常有限的改革方案。所以仅限于改革者和谁有投票权。有一个新的住房分配系统。一些警察改革，所有这些。这简直是你的经典案例，如果你在1963年提供这个，那将是另一个故事，但现在是1968年，你谁也取悦不了。民权活动家说，来吧，这，就像你必须拆除整个歧视
system. You can't just give us this. But on the other side, some of O'Neill's own ministers say, God, you're a total wuss and appeaser. You go over to London, you let them push you around, tell us what to do in our own country. It says, well, Paisley was obviously right about you. You know, you're just a weakling. You don't stand up for Ulster. You're just too interested in pleasing the English. You know, you're basically in an Englishman anyway with your Eaton background.
系统。你不能只给我们这个。但在另一边，奥尼尔自己的一些部长说，天哪，你是个彻头彻尾的懦夫和绥靖者。你去伦敦，让他们推来推去，告诉我们在我们自己的国家该做什么。他说，好吧，佩斯利显然是对的。你知道，你只是个软弱的人。你不为阿尔斯特挺身而出。你只是太热衷于取悦英国人了。你知道，你基本上已经是英国人了，有着伊顿公学的背景。
I mean, just to remind people, this is a guy who'd fought in the Second World War and taken out tank proteins, I imagine. Most people in their story have some sort of war. I mean, it's always the way with 60s and 70s, UK history, isn't it? Set for Jerry Adams. Yes, yes. Well, Amy Pace didn't advise in the war. No doubt made warlike speeches, but I don't think he took out a German machine gun nest or anything like that. It's the shabby men in London, isn't it? Who did that?
我的意思是，提醒一下大家，这是一个参加过第二次世界大战并摧毁了坦克的人，我想是这样。大多数人的故事里都有某种战争。我的意思是，60年代和70年代的英国历史总是这样，不是吗？为杰里·亚当斯（Jerry Adams）设定的。是的，是的。嗯，艾米·佩斯（Amy Pace）并没有在战争中提供建议。毫无疑问，他发表过好战的演讲，但我不认为他摧毁过德国机枪巢之类的东西。那是伦敦那些衣着寒酸的人，不是吗？是谁干的？
Men with glasses, yeah, who become incredibly ineffectual ministers of transport or something. Anyway, so this is the context for O'Neill to give that speech that you read at the beginning. This speech where he basically says to people, look, come on, this is where we are. Peace on one side, total disaster on the other. If you read the text, it's a very sincere appeal. by a man who's clearly exhausted in the end of his tether. He says to the civil rights activists, you know, sure, I'm not going to completely satisfy you,
戴眼镜的人，是的，他们变成了极其无能的交通部长之类的。总之，这就是奥尼尔（O'Neill）发表你开头读到的那篇演讲的背景。在那篇演讲中，他基本上对人们说，看，得了吧，这就是我们的处境。一边是和平，另一边是彻底的灾难。如果你读过原文，那是一个显然已经精疲力竭、走投无路的人发出的非常真诚的呼吁。他对民权活动家说，你知道，当然，我不会完全满足你们，
but this is a democracy, I ask you now with all sincerity, to call your people off the streets. You're Ulstam and yourselves. You know we are all of us stubborn people who will not be pushed too far. And then of his critics, the hardline loyalist critics, he says, they're not merely extremists, they are lunatics who would set a course along a road
但这毕竟是一个民主国家，我现在以全部的诚意请求你们，让你们的人离开街道。你们是阿尔斯特人，你们自己也是。你知道我们所有人都是固执的人，不会被逼得太远。然后谈到他的批评者，那些强硬的保皇派批评者，他说，他们不仅仅是极端分子，他们是疯子，他们会走上一条道路，
which would only lead to an All-Ireland Republic. They're not loyalists, but disloyalists, disloyal to Britain, disloyal to the Constitution, disloyal to the Crown. I mean, it's quite strong stuff. It's punchy, isn't it? It's punchy. And at first, it seems that it might do the trick. Actually, the civil rights campaigners do listen to him.
那只会导致一个全爱尔兰共和国。他们不是保皇派，而是不忠诚者，对英国不忠，对宪法不忠，对王室不忠。我的意思是，这话说得很重。很有冲击力，不是吗？很有冲击力。起初，这似乎可能奏效。事实上，民权运动者确实听了他的话。
They say, fine, we will suspend our demonstrations for a month as an act of goodwill. And the Belfast-Telegraph newspaper organises a petition. I'm backing O'Neill, and they get 150,000 signatures, which is the tenth of the population. But deep down, I think even O'Neill knows that he's actually left this too late. So on Christmas Eve, he wrote a note to his private secretary. He said, 1968 has been a terrible year, but 1969 is going to be even worse. As I look in the glass darkly, I see demonstrations, counter-demonstrations, meetings, rouse, and general misery. And really telling is that at this point, O'Neill says to his secretary,
他们说，好吧，我们将暂停示威一个月，作为一种善意的表现。《贝尔法斯特电讯报》组织了一份请愿书。我支持奥尼尔，他们获得了15万个签名，也就是人口的十分之一。但在内心深处，我想即使是奥尼尔也知道他其实做得太晚了。所以在平安夜，他给他的私人秘书写了一张便条。他说，1968年是糟糕的一年，但1969年将会更糟。当我透过阴暗的玻璃看去，我看到了示威、反示威、会议、争吵和普遍的苦难。真正说明问题的是，在这一点上，奥尼尔对他的秘书说，
The only real solution for this is basically for London to shut us down and impose direct rule from Westminster. But they will never do it. They don't have the courage to do it. And so we will drift from crisis to crisis. Just 10 days after that, the hopes for a sort of peaceful resolution take another big hit. So we talked about the radicalism in 1968. On New Year's Day in 1969, a radical kind of socialist Republican group began a civil rights march from Belfast to date. And this was a group that called themselves People's Democracy.
解决这个问题的唯一真正办法基本上是让伦敦关闭我们，并从威斯敏斯特实施直接统治。但他们永远不会这样做。他们没有勇气这样做。所以我们将从一场危机漂向另一场危机。就在那之后仅仅10天，和平解决的希望又受到了沉重打击。所以我们谈到了1968年的激进主义。1969年元旦，一个激进的社会主义共和派团体开始了一场从贝尔法斯特到德里的民权游行。这是一个自称为“人民民主”（People's Democracy）的团体。
And they'd been founded at Queen's University of Belfast. And their best known member was a young woman called Bernadette Devlin. It was 21 years old. She was a Catholic student, psychology, I think. And the People's Democracy members had been watching Paris and Prague and the American civil rights marches. And they really did want to provoke violent reprisals. Because they said this is the only way to expose.
他们是在贝尔法斯特女王大学成立的。他们最著名的成员是一个叫伯纳黛特·德夫林（Bernadette Devlin）的年轻女子。当时21岁。她是一名天主教学生，我想是学心理学的。人民民主党的成员一直在关注巴黎、布拉格和美国的民权游行。他们确实想挑起暴力报复。因为他们说这是揭露真相的唯一途径。
the true nature of the state we're living in. Sir Bernadette Devlin, what we really wanted to do was to pull the carpet off the floor to show the dirt that was under it. And O'Neill begged them not to go ahead and do this march. Other civil rights activists
我们所生活的国家的真实本质。伯纳黛特·德夫林，我们真正想做的是掀开地毯，露出下面的污垢。奥尼尔恳求他们不要继续进行这次游行。其他民权活动家
asked them not to go on the march. They go on the march? And by the 4th of January, they have reached a place called Bern-Tollett Bridge, which is six miles east of Derry. And here, 400 loyalists are waiting for
要求他们不要参加游行。他们去参加游行了吗？到1月4日，他们到达了一个叫伯恩特莱特桥（Burntollet Bridge）的地方，那里在德里以东六英里处。在这里，400名保皇派正在等待
them armed with sticks and stones and iron bars and cudgels studded with nails and many of these people waiting in ambush are off-duty be specials and they absolutely lay into the student marches beating their living daylights out of them and meanwhile members of the police the r uc are standing there watching and doing absolutely nothing and it's covered on tv and it's basically just what Bernadette Devlin and the other marches had expected in a way what they wanted. And this is, I think, is a really good example at the point that we were talking about earlier. People often talk about the troubles as though they sort of arise organically by accident or by magic. Actually, this is a really good example of how they are willed into being by people who could have made different choices.
他们，手里拿着棍棒、石头、铁棍和钉着钉子的短棍，这些埋伏的人中许多是休班的“B特遣队”（B Specials），他们绝对是痛打学生游行者，把他们打得落花流水，与此同时，警察（RUC）成员站在那里看着，什么也没做，电视上报道了这件事，这基本上就是伯纳黛特·德夫林和其他游行者所预料的，在某种程度上，这正是他们想要的。我认为，这是我们之前谈到的那一点的一个很好的例子。人们经常谈论“动乱”（The Troubles），好像它们是偶然或魔法有机地产生的。事实上，这是一个很好的例子，说明它们是如何被那些本可以做出不同选择的人有意制造出来的。
Because as we said, lots of other civil rights campaigners had said, please don't go on this march. You'll only make things worse. They thought that by marching through, I mean, the People's Democracy March goes through the small Protestant towns of County Antrim. And they said, don't do this. It is needlessly provocative. But Bernadette Deflin and Co., their attitude was, well, we're suffering terrible discrimination.
因为正如我们所说，许多其他民权运动者曾说，请不要参加这次游行。你们只会让事情变得更糟。他们认为通过游行，我的意思是，人民民主党的游行穿过了安特里姆郡的小型新教城镇。他们说，不要这样做。这是不必要的挑衅。但伯纳黛特·德夫林和她的同伴，他们的态度是，好吧，我们正在遭受可怕的歧视。
We want to provoke people. We want the reaction. We want the publicity. And of course, on the other side, the loyalists didn't have to turn up with their kind of cudgels and nails. I mean, they could have just let them do it. They could have just let them march. It just, their strategy seems mad.
我们想挑衅人们。我们想要这种反应。我们想要宣传。当然，在另一边，保皇派也不必带着他们的棍棒和钉子出现。我的意思是，他们本可以让他们这么做。他们本可以让他们游行。这只是，他们的策略看起来很疯狂。
I mean, it's like the nationalists have said, here's an elephant trap. Oh, brilliant. Let's jump into it. It's just lunatic behavior from them. They would say, we're defending our state from people who want to destroy it. I mean, I know what they say, but they have failed to understand how it will play on the screens of the world. I mean, I suppose they would say they don't care. I suppose they would say they don't care, but I agree with you that so they haven't been watching TV.
我的意思是，这就像民族主义者说，这是一个大象陷阱。哦，太棒了。让我们跳进去吧。这简直是他们的疯狂行为。他们会说，我们正在保卫我们的国家，抵御那些想要摧毁它的人。我的意思是，我知道他们是怎么说的，但他们没有理解这在世界屏幕上会产生什么影响。我的意思是，我想他们会说他们不在乎。我想他们会说他们不在乎，但我同意你的看法，所以他们没有看电视。
Because when Martin Luther King did his marches in America, the ones that were, best were the ones where the forces of authority or white racists or whatever showed the ugly side to their society. And if you don't do that, then it's much harder to cut through with the public. To cast yourself as the victim. Of course. So I think everybody involved in that burnt toilet bridge story, you know, they got what they wanted. And the person who loses most is, of course, the one person who's trying to hold the whole thing
因为当马丁·路德·金在美国进行游行时，效果最好的是那些权威力量或白人种族主义者或其他什么人展示了他们社会丑陋一面的游行。如果你不这样做，那么就很难引起公众的共鸣。把自己塑造成受害者。当然。所以我认为参与那个伯恩特莱特桥故事的每个人，你知道，他们得到了他们想要的。而损失最大的人，当然是那个试图把整件事维持在一起的人，
together, which is Terrence O'Neill. because this is terrible for him because first of all, Catholics say but these TV pictures of people being beaten once again shows the state will not protect us the RUC will not protect us the B specials are not the solution
那就是特伦斯·奥尼尔（Terrence O'Neill）。因为这对他是可怕的，因为首先，天主教徒说，但这些人们被殴打的电视画面再次表明，国家不会保护我们，RUC不会保护我们，B特遣队不是解决方案，
they are the problem they are violent, bigoted sectarian they cannot be reformed all this on the other hand the loyalists and unionists say or burnt hollet bridge shows that the civil rights activists they're only interested in provoking disorder
他们是问题所在，他们是暴力的、偏执的宗派主义者，他们无法被改革。另一方面，保皇派和统一派说，伯恩特莱特桥表明，民权活动家只对挑起混乱感兴趣。
They deliberately sought to provoke chaos because they want to undermine our state And Terrence O'Neill has given them far too much He makes concessions but it's never enough for them Somebody one day will have to stand up to these people This is what both sides say And this leads O'Neill in a really, really tricky position And what he decides to do He says basically sod it
他们蓄意寻求挑起混乱，因为他们想破坏我们的国家。而特伦斯·奥尼尔给了他们太多。他做出了让步，但这对他们来说永远不够。总有一天有人必须站出来对抗这些人。这就是双方所说的。这让奥尼尔处于一个非常、非常棘手的境地。他决定怎么做，他基本上说去他的，
I'm going to gamble everything And on the 3rd of February He decides to throw the dice He says I'm going to dissolve the parliament in Stormont, I only call a general election, and I'm going to say to the people of Northern Ireland, what do you want? Do you want peace or do you want civil war? Back me or sack me.
我要赌上一切。在2月3日，他决定掷骰子。他说，我要解散斯托蒙特（Stormont）的议会，我只呼吁举行大选，我要对北爱尔兰人民说，你们想要什么？你们想要和平还是想要内战？支持我还是解雇我。
I mean, he's taking a massive risk. And at the point that he's doing that, in London, Harold Wilson's government at last finally wake up to how serious this is and they say, God, we're going to have to think about a doomsday scenario here. So just six days afterwards, Callahan tells one of his cabinet colleagues, Richard Crossman, who writes a diary, he says, we have been drawn. drawing up a contingency plan. If things go wrong for Terrence O'Neill in this election,
我的意思是，他在冒巨大的风险。在他这样做的时候，在伦敦，哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）的政府终于意识到这有多严重，他们说，天哪，我们必须考虑这里的世界末日情景。所以仅仅6天后，卡拉汉（Callaghan）告诉他的内阁同事理查德·克罗斯曼（Richard Crossman），他写了一本日记，他说，我们一直在制定应急计划。如果特伦斯·奥尼尔在这次选举中失败，
we may have to send British troops into the streets of Northern Ireland and to take over the government ourselves. So, as the people of Northern Ireland prepare to go to the polls, the stakes could not be higher, not least for O'Neill himself, because in his own constituency, in Bandside in Antrim, where for election after election he has been unopposed, he now faces a challenge from a union and, hardliner, a rival unionist. And Dominant, who is this unionist hardliner? Surprise, surprise. It is the
我们可能不得不派遣英国军队进入北爱尔兰的街道，并亲自接管政府。因此，当北爱尔兰人民准备去投票时，赌注再高不过了，尤其是对奥尼尔本人而言，因为在他自己的选区，在安特里姆的班赛德（Bandside），他一届又一届的选举中都没有对手，现在他面临着来自一位统一派强硬分子、一位竞争对手统一派的挑战。而多米南特，这位统一派强硬分子是谁？惊喜，惊喜。他是
Reverend Ian Paisley. Unbelievable. Okay, we'll come back after the break to find out what happens in this Titanic clash. This episode is brought to you by Amazon. Now, ever since the Industrial Revolution, one of the great themes of capitalist society has been the desire to reform and improve injustices. And I suppose a classic example of this would be the drive in the Victorian period to stop young children being sent up chimneys to work there as sweeps. Yeah, and you can draw a thread, can't you, between the fight for kind of better rights for workers and better working conditions and benefits and things in the 19th century, all the way through to what happens in the 21st. So a good example of the kind of benefits that employees get these days, the benefits that Amazon offers
伊恩·佩斯利（Ian Paisley）牧师。难以置信。好吧，休息后我们回来看看这场泰坦尼克式的冲突中发生了什么。本集由亚马逊赞助。现在，自从工业革命以来，资本主义社会的一大主题就是改革和改善不公正现象的愿望。我想一个经典的例子就是维多利亚时代推动停止派遣年幼儿童上烟囱去做清扫工。是的，你可以画一条线，不是吗，在争取工人更好的权利和更好的工作条件、福利等方面的斗争之间，从19世纪一直到21世纪发生的事情。所以一个很好的例子是员工如今获得的福利，亚马逊提供的福利
to its employees, so they get funding of up to £3,000 a year, every year, towards training and career growth. And Amazon offers term time working to employees with school-age children so they can apply to get a guaranteed 10 weeks off in the year to coincide with school holidays, all the while continuing to have access to their full benefits. Find out more at about amazon.com.uk slash benefits dash and dash workplace. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers, the rest is science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. When we talk about beating cancer, we often focus a lot on survival.
给它的员工，所以他们每年获得高达3000英镑的培训和职业发展资金。亚马逊为有学龄儿童的员工提供学期工作制，因此他们可以申请保证每年有10周的假期，与学校假期相吻合，同时继续享受他们的全部福利。在about amazon.com.uk slash benefits dash and dash workplace了解更多信息。嘿，这是来自Gollhangers的迈克尔和汉娜，《其余的是科学》（The Rest is Science）。本集由英国癌症研究中心（Cancer Research UK）赞助。当我们谈论战胜癌症时，我们经常把重点放在生存上。
And that can mean overlooking impacts that last long after treatment ends. Yeah, for example, take cancers in children and young people. the treatments themselves can be incredibly harsh. They can cause lifelong side effects like infertility or hearing loss. And Cancer Research UK is working to change that because young people, they should be able to grow up hearing the voices of the people that they love and living their lives at the fullest. That's right.
这可能意味着忽视治疗结束后持续很久的影响。是的，例如，以儿童和年轻人的癌症为例。治疗本身可能极其严酷。它们会导致终身的副作用，如不孕不育或听力损失。英国癌症研究中心正在努力改变这一点，因为年轻人，他们应该能够长大后听到他们所爱之人的声音，并充实地生活。没错。
And one clinical trial led by Cancer Research UK showed that giving another drug alongside chemotherapy nearly halved the number of children losing their hearing. And today, the treatment combination is being used by doctors, across the world. For more information about Cancer Research UK, their research and breakthroughs, and how you can support them, visit cancerresearchuk.org slash rest is science. Hola, Camaradas. It's Dominic here. Sorry to interrupt the episode, but I just thought you'd like to know that we've been thinking about something that you've been writing to us a lot, one of the most requested subjects ever since we started the Restis history, which is the Spanish Civil War.
英国癌症研究中心领导的一项临床试验表明，在化疗的同时给予另一种药物，使听力受损的儿童人数减少了近一半。今天，这种治疗组合正被世界各地的医生使用。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究和突破以及你如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问cancerresearchuk.org slash rest is science。Hola，同志们。我是多米尼克。抱歉打断这一集，但我只是想让你知道，我们一直在思考你们写信给我们很多次的一件事，这是我们开始《其余的是历史》（The Rest is History）以来最受要求的主题之一，那就是西班牙内战。
Now, I can tell you exclusively that plans are afoot for us to do the Spanish Civil War at some point, hopefully next year in 2027. But as a little taster or teaser on our sister show, The Book Club, my co-presenter, Tabby and I have just released an episode on perhaps the emblematic novel of the Spanish Civil War, which is Ernest Hemingway's book for whom the bell tolls. So in this episode, we do dig into the history. We talk about the clash between fascism and idealism. We talk about the roots of the conflict. And, of course, the way in which it drew in so many foreign intellectuals and artists and writers. Hemingway, of course, among them. And many of you will know that Hemingway was in Spain during the war.
现在，我可以独家告诉你，我们计划在某个时候进行西班牙内战，希望是在明年2027年。但作为我们姐妹节目《读书俱乐部》（The Book Club）的一点小品尝或预告，我和我的联合主持人塔比刚刚发布了一集关于也许是西班牙内战标志性小说的节目，那就是欧内斯特·海明威（Ernest Hemingway）的书《丧钟为谁而鸣》（For Whom the Bell Tolls）。所以在这集里，我们深入探讨了历史。我们谈论了法西斯主义和理想主义之间的冲突。我们谈论了冲突的根源。当然，还有它吸引了如此多外国知识分子、艺术家和作家的方式。海明威当然也在其中。你们很多人会知道海明威在战争期间在西班牙。
He was a correspondent in Madrid, which was under siege by Franco's forces. And he draws on that experience in for whom the belt holds to tell the story of an American volunteer who's part of a guerrilla unit who are fighting for. Franco's troops. So if you keep listening at the end of this episode, we will have an exclusive short clip which discusses the history of the Spanish Civil War. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest of history, where it is the evening of the 24th of February, 1969, and the polls have closed in the elections for a northern Irish parliament at Stormont. And the mood is incredibly tense, isn't it? Because for the last few weeks. The Reverend Ian Paisley has been tramping the streets with bands and drummers and
他是马德里的通讯员，当时马德里正被佛朗哥（Franco）的军队围困。他在《丧钟为谁而鸣》中利用了那段经历，讲述了一名美国志愿者的故事，他是游击队的一员，正在为佛朗哥的军队而战。所以如果你在本集结束时继续收听，我们将有一个独家短片，讨论西班牙内战的历史。大家好，欢迎回到《其余的是历史》，现在是1969年2月24日的晚上，北爱尔兰斯托蒙特议会的选举投票已经结束。气氛非常紧张，不是吗？因为在过去的几周里。伊恩·佩斯利牧师一直在带着乐队和鼓手在街上游行，
holding up Bibles and he's been denouncing the traitor who will soon be crushed beneath the marching fate of the Protestants. This takes the highest-o-sand-band side. Terence O'Neill's supporters are watching very anxiously as the pile of Ian Paisley's votes is going to getting higher and higher and higher. And eventually the result comes through and Terrence O'Neill has just scraped home. He's won a majority of just 1,400 votes over Paisley, and this for somebody who had always been unopposed before is a real shock. But actually, this is the only good news that he gets of the night. Because when you look at the rest of the results, they're very confused. He hasn't got the mandate that he wanted. In working-class Protestant areas, moderate unionism has hemorrhage support.
举着圣经，他一直在谴责那个很快就会被新教徒的行军脚步踩碎的叛徒。这在班赛德（Bandside）达到了最高点。特伦斯·奥尼尔的支持者们非常焦虑地看着伊恩·佩斯利的选票堆得越来越高。最终结果出来了，特伦斯·奥尼尔只是勉强获胜。他以1400票的多数票战胜了佩斯利，对于一个以前总是没有对手的人来说，这真是一个打击。但实际上，这是他当晚得到的唯一好消息。因为当你看看其余的结果时，它们非常混乱。他没有得到他想要的授权。在工人阶级新教地区，温和的统一主义已经流失了支持。
The hardliners have done very well, and his party, although the unionists are still in control of stormments, of course, their party is now very deeply fractured. And after this, it's the classic story, you know, a prime minister calls a snap election to try and shore up their authority. They don't get the mandate they wanted, and after that they're basically a dead man walking. And the end for O'Neill comes a few weeks later, and it comes in very dramatic circumstances. On the evening of the 30th of March, 1969, he's waiting for a vote of confidence from the Ulster Unionist Council when a bomb goes off at the Castle-ray electricity substation, and that plunges half of Belfast into darkness.
强硬派做得很好，他的政党，虽然统一派当然仍然控制着斯托蒙特，但他们的政党现在已经非常严重地分裂了。在此之后，这是一个经典的故事，你知道，一位首相为了巩固自己的权威而提前举行大选。他们没有得到他们想要的授权，此后他们基本上就是一个行尸走肉。奥尼尔的结局在几周后到来，而且是在非常戏剧性的情况下。1969年3月30日晚上，他正在等待阿尔斯特统一主义委员会（Ulster Unionist Council）的信任投票，这时卡斯尔雷（Castle-ray）变电站发生了一起炸弹爆炸，这使贝尔法斯特的一半陷入了黑暗。
And in the next few weeks, there are more bombs at water installations and water pipelines and electricity stations. And so by the 26th March, much of Belfast is without water. There are actually trucks crawling through the streets, giving water to people who can't get to standpipes. Now, in his Protestant telegraph, Ian Paisley says this is the handiwork of the IRA. loyalists must now appreciate the struggle that lies ahead and the supreme sacrifice that will have to be made
在接下来的几周里，供水设施、输水管道和发电站又发生了更多的炸弹袭击。因此，到3月26日，贝尔法斯特大部分地区没有水。实际上有卡车在街上爬行，给那些无法到达立管的人供水。现在，在他的《新教电讯报》（Protestant Telegraph）中，伊恩·佩斯利说这是爱尔兰共和军（IRA）的杰作。保皇派现在必须意识到前方等待的斗争和将要作出的最高牺牲，
in order that Ulster will remain Protestant. But do you know what, the irony of this is? These bombs weren't planted by the IRA. They were planted by the Ulster Volunteer Force working alongside Ian Paisley's own Ulster Protestant volunteers. Which Paisley presumably knew about? He must have known about it, surely. So he was lying?
为了让阿尔斯特保持新教。但你知道这有什么讽刺意味吗？这些炸弹不是爱尔兰共和军放置的。它们是由阿尔斯特志愿军（UVF）与伊恩·佩斯利自己的阿尔斯特新教志愿者合作放置的。佩斯利大概知道这件事？他一定知道，肯定。所以他在撒谎？
I guess so yeah Yeah he was I mean that's poor from a man of the cloth Remember the bloke we met last time Who runs the UVF Gusty Spence Oh the guy who shot everyone in pubs Yeah
我想是的，是的。是的，他是。我的意思是，对于一个神职人员来说，这很糟糕。还记得我们上次见到的那个经营UVF的家伙吗？古斯蒂·斯彭斯（Gusty Spence）。哦，那个在酒吧里枪杀所有人的家伙。是的。
He's in prison at this point Because he's been Because of his pub shooting record Although he actually denied That he'd pull the trigger He's in prison And he says quite openly afterwards He says we did this
他此时在监狱里。因为他因为他的酒吧枪击记录。虽然他实际上否认他扣动了扳机。他在监狱里，他事后非常公开地说。他说我们做了这个，
To expose O'Neill's weakness To show people that he would be He would be soft on the IRA If the IRA were to blow things up It was carefully planned to bring down O'Neill, to quote him directly. And it works. Because two days after the peak of the water business,
为了暴露奥尼尔的软弱。向人们展示他会对爱尔兰共和军软弱。如果爱尔兰共和军要炸毁东西。这是经过精心策划的，目的是推翻奥尼尔，直接引用他的话。而且它奏效了。因为在水危机达到顶峰两天后，
O'Neill resigns as Prime Minister. He's absolutely exhausted. He's totally demoralised. He can't see any future to a prosperous future for Northern Ireland. And when he goes on TV to explain this, he's completely candid. He says, the old fears, the old prejudices, the old loyalties were too much for me and I couldn't overcome them. I suppose the problem for him was that he seemed too kind of posh,
奥尼尔辞去了首相职务。他绝对精疲力竭。他完全士气低落。他看不到北爱尔兰有任何繁荣的未来。当他上电视解释这一点时，他非常坦率。他说，旧的恐惧、旧的偏见、旧的忠诚对我来说太多了，我无法克服它们。我想他的问题在于他看起来太像那种时髦的、
landed, two grand. And so I imagine that the obvious strategy for his party is to elect as his replacement, someone with roots in the local community, someone who, you know, the average guy in the pub on the Shankill Road could identify with. So is that what they do? No. They basically choose the same person again. I mean, this is a bit harsh because there are differences.
有土地的，太高贵了。所以我认为对他所在的政党来说，显而易见的策略是选举一个在当地社区有根基的人作为他的继任者，一个你知道，在尚基尔路（Shankill Road）酒吧里的普通人可以认同的人。那么他们是这样做的吗？不。他们基本上再次选择了同一个人。我的意思是，这有点苛刻，因为有差异。
But the person they choose is yet another member of the landed gentry. and he's James Chichester Clark. He's a landowner from County Londonderry. So Terrence O'Neillian may remember went to Eton. James Chichester Clark went to Eton. So he's another old Etonian. Yeah. He joined the Irish Guards.
但他们选择的人又是另一个土地贵族成员。他是詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克（James Chichester Clark）。他是伦敦德里郡的一名地主。所以特伦斯·奥尼尔你可能记得去了伊顿公学。詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克去了伊顿公学。所以他是另一个老伊顿生。是的。他加入了爱尔兰卫队。
I think actually Terence O'Neill did as well. He rose to a major. He was at Anseo. Oh, so better than O'Neill. Yeah, exactly. He was wounded at Anseo and he was left with injurers that played him all his life. He is more hard-line. than O'Neill. He'd actually resigned
我想实际上特伦斯·奥尼尔也加入了。他升到了少校。他在安齐奥（Anzio）。哦，所以比奥尼尔好。是的，完全正确。他在安齐奥受伤，留下了困扰他一生的伤痛。他比奥尼尔更强硬。他实际上辞职了，
because he didn't agree with the way they were bringing in one man, one vote. But O'Neill is more urbane. Chichester Clark is a bit of a farmer. He's sort of slow. He's a bit wooden. He's very earnest. He has no sort of flair or imagination. And Ian Paisley, when he was asked,
因为他不同意他们引入一人一票的方式。但奥尼尔更文雅。奇切斯特-克拉克有点像个农民。他有点慢。他有点木讷。他非常认真。他没有任何天赋或想象力。伊恩·佩斯利，当他被问到，
what do you make of Chichester Clark? He said, I've already taken down a captain. I reckon I can handle a major. So, ominous. And Chichester Clark inherits a situation that's now really spiraling out of control. role. So in Derry, we talked about Derry, in Derry, random sectarian violence has become much more common. People being beaten up at night. You're walking down the street. There's a
你觉得奇切斯特-克拉克怎么样？他说，我已经打倒了一个上尉。我想我可以对付一个少校。所以，不祥之兆。奇切斯特-克拉克继承了一个现在真的失控的情况。角色。所以在德里，我们谈到了德里，在德里，随机的宗派暴力变得更加普遍。人们在晚上被殴打。你走在街上。有一个
group of men. They say to you, what's your name, where are you from? If you give the wrong answer, they basically kick the living daylights out of you. There's a terrible story which is in the headlines at this point. So in Derry, in the Bogside District, a group of policemen had invaded the home of a taxi driver called Samuel Dauveni, and they beat him. up so badly that he later died of his injuries. And this is a huge scandal. And on top of all this, there was just been a by-election in Mid Ulster, a Westminster by-election, and the winner was the 21-year-old Bernadette Deflin of the People's Democracy Group, who at the time became the youngest woman ever to win a Westminster seat. And she gave her maiden speech on 22nd of April in the Commons,
一群人。他们对你说，你叫什么名字，你从哪里来？如果你给出错误的答案，他们基本上会把你打得落花流水。有一个可怕的故事，此时在头条新闻中。所以在德里，在博格赛德（Bogside）区，一群警察入侵了一名出租车司机塞缪尔·道维尼（Samuel Dauveni）的家，他们把他打得非常严重，以至于他后来因伤死亡。这是一个巨大的丑闻。最重要的是，中阿尔斯特刚刚举行了一次补选，威斯敏斯特补选，获胜者是人民民主党的21岁的伯纳黛特·德夫林，她当时成为有史以来赢得威斯敏斯特席位的最年轻的女性。她在4月22日在下议院发表了她的处女演讲，
in London, Westminster. She gave a speech that got enormous attention and praise at the especially from sort of more left-leaning papers in Britain. She said there can be no justice in Northern Ireland while the unionists run it. They are corrupt, bigoted and self-interested. She basically dared Harold Wilson to abolish Stormont and rule Northern Ireland from Westminster. I was reading the speech yesterday. It's a very telling moment. She says to him, people are saying now maybe you could send in troops to keep the peace.
在伦敦，威斯敏斯特。她发表了一场引起巨大关注和赞扬的演讲，特别是来自英国一些更倾向于左翼的报纸。她说，只要统一派管理北爱尔兰，北爱尔兰就不可能有正义。他们是腐败的、偏执的和自私的。她基本上敢于让哈罗德·威尔逊废除斯托蒙特，并从威斯敏斯特统治北爱尔兰。我昨天在读那篇演讲。这是一个非常说明问题的时刻。她对他说，人们现在说也许你可以派军队去维持和平。
She says, this is a very bad idea. If British troops are sent in, I should not like to be. either the mother or the sister of her unfortunate soldier station there. The one point in common among Ulstermen is they are not very fond of Englishmen who tell them what to do. So they'll be enjoying this podcast. Surely. I suspect that what Northern Ireland audience we have switched off when they heard
她说，这是一个非常糟糕的主意。如果英国军队被派去，我不想成为驻扎在那里的不幸士兵的母亲或姐妹。阿尔斯特人共同的一点是，他们不太喜欢告诉他们该怎么做的英国人。所以他们会喜欢这个播客。肯定。我怀疑我们有什么北爱尔兰听众在听到
the first two minutes of the first episode and the dulcet tones of Ian Paisley being performed by somebody from Wiltshire. Can I just say? I checked with my friend Michael Taylor, who is from Ulster. Yeah, a man of very strong opinions, no? He has very strong opinions, and he's, you know, he wouldn't be afraid to tell me that I was making a catastrophic mistake. I'll tell you what he said. He said, I would love to hear it.
第一集的前两分钟和由威尔特郡某人表演的伊恩·佩斯利的甜美语调时就关掉了。我能说吗？我向我的朋友迈克尔·泰勒（Michael Taylor）核实过，他是阿尔斯特人。是的，一个非常有强烈观点的人，不是吗？他有非常强烈的观点，而且他，你知道，他不会害怕告诉我我犯了一个灾难性的错误。我告诉你他说了什么。他说，我很想听听。
He'd be the third great Balamina figure to feature on the show after Neeson and Casement. Well, and we've had Neeson again. Yeah. In some ways, too much Liam Neeson on this show, I think. He's like the Welsh, just keeps getting in. All right. So Bernard Dufflin has given her speech. What's Harold Wilson up to? Wilson and his government, you know, they've lost Terrence O'Neill now. They've got this other bloke. Chishister Clark. And on the 7th of May, the cabinet have a meeting. And Jim Callahan says to, look, you know, I know we hate talking about Northern Ireland because it's really boring. But we have to talk about it. Here are the different options. And he says, one of the options is we could send in troops and run the province ourselves. And loads of Harold Wilson's ministers to say, oh, that's mad. No, we don't know anything about this. Best not get involved. We don't know anything about it.
他将是继尼森（Neeson）和凯斯门特（Casement）之后出现在节目中的第三位伟大的巴利米纳（Balamina）人物。好吧，我们又有了尼森。是的。我觉得这个节目里连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson）太多了。他就像威尔士人，总是不断出现。好吧。所以伯纳黛特·德夫林发表了她的演讲。哈罗德·威尔逊在做什么？威尔逊和他的政府，你知道，他们现在失去了特伦斯·奥尼尔。他们有这个其他人。奇切斯特-克拉克。在5月7日，内阁开了一个会。吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callahan）对他说，看，你知道，我知道我们讨厌谈论北爱尔兰，因为它真的很无聊。但我们必须谈谈。这里有不同的选择。他说，其中一个选择是我们派军队去，自己管理这个省。哈罗德·威尔逊的许多部长说，哦，那太疯狂了。不，我们对这个一无所知。最好不要参与。我们对它一无所知。
So Dennis Healy, the Defence Secretary, also an Anzio man, of course, with their famous hinterland. Dennis Healy says, and I quote, it would be crazy to go in there and take things over. We would be siding with the Roman Catholics and the civil rights movement against the government and the IUC,
所以丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healy），国防大臣，当然也是安齐奥人，有着他们著名的腹地。丹尼斯·希利说，我引用一下，进去接管事情会很疯狂。我们将站在罗马天主教徒和民权运动一边，反对政府和RUC，
although we know nothing at all about it. That line, we know nothing at all about it. The amazing thing about this, I think that it's so comical in some ways that runs through this story for about 10 years, as people in Britain say, well, obviously we know nothing at all about this, and we never will.
虽然我们对它一无所知。那句话，我们对它一无所知。我认为这件事令人惊奇的是，它在某些方面非常滑稽，贯穿了这个故事大约10年，因为英国人说，好吧，显然我们对这个一无所知，而且永远也不会知道。
So let's either not get involved or just make terrible, random decisions. But obviously, informing themselves about it would be that landish. Yeah, I mean, he wants to bother with something as dull as that. Whenever they say, we know nothing about it, they talk as though that's like a fact of nature
所以让我们要么不参与，要么只是做出可怕的、随机的决定。但显然，了解它将是离谱的。是的，我的意思是，他想打扰像那样枯燥的事情。每当他们说，我们对它一无所知时，他们说话就好像那是一个自然事实
or an act of God that cannot possibly be remedied, and they shouldn't be ashamed of it. Isn't that a legacy of how intractive, the Irish question was in the early decades of the 20th century, that it's hardwired into British politicians. We don't understand this. We don't understand this. And there's something wrong with you if you take an excessive interest in it. It's somehow suspect to be overly informed about this. And the best thing to do is to take no interest in it whatsoever. Of course, though, the British government may not be interested in Northern Ireland, but Northern
或者是上帝的行为，不可能补救，他们不应该为此感到羞耻。这不是20世纪初爱尔兰问题有多棘手的遗产吗，它已经深深植根于英国政治家心中。我们不理解这个。我们不理解这个。如果你对它表现出过度的兴趣，你就有问题。对这个过于了解在某种程度上是可疑的。最好的办法是根本不对此产生任何兴趣。当然，英国政府可能对北爱尔兰不感兴趣，但北
Ireland's going to be interested in them. And a big theme of this story is that British governments are constantly sort of struggling to catch up because they are always behind the pace of events. So the 12th of July, there are big parades. This is the high point of what's called the marching season. So for people unfamiliar with Northern Ireland, there are annual parades held by the Orange Order and other Protestant societies to celebrate things like the Battle of the Boyne in 1690. And they are always tense. And this time, 12th of July, 1969, the sort of fighting and rioting surrounding the parades is worse than ever. And in the next few weeks there is more rioting, especially in Belfast, you have rival gangs
爱尔兰会对他们感兴趣。这个故事的一个大主题是，英国政府不断地在努力追赶，因为他们总是落后于事件的步伐。所以7月12日，有大型游行。这是所谓的“行军季节”的高潮。所以对于不熟悉北爱尔兰的人来说，奥兰治会（Orange Order）和其他新教社团每年都会举行游行，以庆祝1690年的博因河战役（Battle of the Boyne）等事件。它们总是很紧张。而这一次，1969年7月12日，游行周围的战斗和骚乱比以往任何时候都更严重。在接下来的几周里，有更多的骚乱，特别是在贝尔法斯特，你有敌对的帮派
forcing Catholic and Protestant families out of their homes, you know, different gangs. And everybody knows the next flashpoint will come on the 12th of August, because this is the annual March of the Apprentice Boys of Derry. So this is the biggest of all Northern Ireland's Protestant parades. and it commemorates the relief of Derry by William of Orange's troops in 1689. Derry had been under siege by James II and the sort of Jacobite army and the Protestant William of Orange, William III, relieved the city. And it's seen as this totemic moment in the history of Ulster Protestants.
强迫天主教和新教家庭离开他们的家园，你知道，不同的帮派。每个人都知道下一个爆发点将在8月12日到来，因为这是德里学徒男孩（Apprentice Boys of Derry）的年度游行。所以这是北爱尔兰所有新教游行中规模最大的一次。它纪念1689年威廉三世（William of Orange）的军队对德里的解围。德里一直被詹姆斯二世（James II）和雅各布派军队围困，新教徒威廉三世，威廉三世，解救了这座城市。它被视为阿尔斯特新教徒历史上的一个图腾时刻。
And they mark it every year, 15,000 members of the Orange Order marched through the streets Flutes, drums, they're wearing the sashes, they've got the bowler hats on. They would say, I mean, they do say to this day, this is an expression. It's one of our great communal traditions and expression of our history, of our culture, of our identity. There was that famous image of an American tourist in a cab getting caught up in it and thinking it was great and kind of grooving along to it. Loving Irish customs. Yeah, exactly. I remember that.
他们每年都纪念它，15000名奥兰治会成员走在街上，长笛、鼓，他们戴着腰带，戴着圆顶礼帽。他们会说，我的意思是，他们至今仍然说，这是一种表达。这是我们伟大的社区传统之一，是我们历史、文化、身份的表达。有一张著名的照片，一个美国游客在出租车里被卷入其中，认为这很棒，并随着它律动。热爱爱尔兰习俗。是的，完全正确。我记得那个。
Yeah, that was so comical. Now, obviously, in 1969, this is going to be incredibly fraught. James Chichester Clark could ban it. He has the power to ban it. But of course he's not going to because that would tank his reputation among the Protestants of Northern Ireland.
是的，那太滑稽了。现在，显然，在1969年，这将是非常令人紧张的。詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克可以禁止它。他有权禁止它。但当然他不会，因为那会摧毁他在北爱尔兰新教徒中的声誉。
And it would be a massive gift to Ian Paisley. He's never going to ban it. James Callaghan as Home Secretary could ban it. But Callahan decides, I'm not going to ban it. A delegation of Labour Backbenches went to see him and said, come on, Jim, what are you going to do about this march? He said, we have a policy we don't interfere in Northern Ireland.
这对伊恩·佩斯利来说将是一份巨大的礼物。他永远不会禁止它。詹姆斯·卡拉汉作为内政大臣可以禁止它。但卡拉汉决定，我不打算禁止它。一群工党后座议员去见他，说，得了吧，吉姆，你打算怎么处理这次游行？他说，我们有一项政策，我们不干涉北爱尔兰。
The problems of Northern Ireland should be solved within Northern Ireland without any outside intervention. Goes back to your point about the Irish question. Basically, he would say we've learned in Britain to stay out of Ireland and to get involved as little as possible because when we do it always goes wrong. But of course, this means the march goes ahead and this sets the stay to one of the landmark set-piece confrontations of the entire troubles. So in early August, in Derry, the Catholic. Catholics are preparing for a fight.
北爱尔兰的问题应该在北爱尔兰内部解决，没有任何外部干预。回到你关于爱尔兰问题的观点。基本上，他会说我们在英国已经学会了远离爱尔兰，并尽可能少地参与，因为当我们这样做时，它总是会出错。但当然，这意味着游行继续进行，这为整个动乱的标志性定点对抗之一奠定了基础。所以8月初，在德里，天主教徒。天主教徒正在准备战斗。
They have set up a Citizens Defence Association under an IRA veteran called Sean Keenan. They are stockpiling petrol bombs. They are planning barricades at street corners. They're preparing for trouble. We get to the night of the 11th, the day before the parade. The first barricades go up in the Catholic bogside area. But in the Protestant areas, people have already lit bonfires celebrating the parade. Everybody knows this is going to be very, you know, it's going to be very,
他们在一名叫肖恩·基南（Sean Keenan）的爱尔兰共和军老兵的领导下成立了一个公民防御协会。他们正在囤积汽油弹。他们正在计划在街角设置路障。他们正在为麻烦做准备。我们到了11日的晚上，游行的前一天。第一批路障出现在天主教博格赛德区。但在新教地区，人们已经点燃了篝火庆祝游行。每个人都知道这将是非常，你知道，这将是非常，
spicy tomorrow. The 12th dawns, a noon, the apprentice boys as they're called, the kind of fraternal order and their allies. They form into parade order on the city walls. And below, there are groups of kind of Catholic teenagers and young men are shouting abuse up at them, and they're throwing coins down, sort of traditional gesture of contempt. They're throwing pennies down at the Catholics below. A couple of hours later, the first scuffles break out. People are throwing nails and stones as the apprentice boys set off on their march. The RUC, the police, have put barriers to keep the two sides apart, but by late afternoon, most of these barriers have been dismantled, and basically the march was degenerated into a kind of general melee. At this point, desperate to kind of regain
明天很火爆。12日黎明，所谓的学徒男孩，那种兄弟会和他们的盟友。他们在城墙上排成游行队形。在下面，有一群天主教青少年和年轻人对着他们大喊大叫，他们向下扔硬币，这是一种传统的蔑视姿态。他们向下面的天主教徒扔便士。几个小时后，第一次冲突爆发了。当学徒男孩开始游行时，人们扔钉子和石头。RUC，警察，设置了障碍物以保持双方分开，但到下午晚些时候，这些障碍物大部分已被拆除，游行基本上演变成了一种普遍的混战。此时，渴望恢复
control of the streets, the RUC launch a baton charge into the bog side. So this is a kind of fairly tightly packed Catholic area of London Derry or Derry. And when they go advanced, they're actually walking into a trap because the Derry Citizens Defence Association, they've got kids with petrol bombs on top of the high-rise flats at the entrance to the bogside. So they're throwing down these petrol bombs. And as night falls, there's a scene of total chaos. There are batten charges, petrol bombs, there are burning shops. The IUC bring up their water cannons. They start firing tear gas. It's an incredible sort of scene of disorder. By dawn the next morning, which is the 13th, the Bogside has basically become a battle zone.
对街道的控制，RUC向博格赛德发起了警棍冲锋。所以这是一个相当拥挤的伦敦德里或德里的天主教区。当他们前进时，他们实际上是走进了一个陷阱，因为德里公民防御协会，他们在博格赛德入口处的高层公寓顶上有带着汽油弹的孩子。所以他们向下扔这些汽油弹。随着夜幕降临，出现了完全混乱的场景。有警棍冲锋、汽油弹、燃烧的商店。RUC带来了他们的水炮。他们开始发射催泪瓦斯。这是一种令人难以置信的混乱场景。到第二天早上，也就是13日，博格赛德基本上变成了一个战区。
The RUC camped at just outside it, kind of holding a front line. Inside it, people have set up emergency first aid stations. They've got women and children and kind of relays making petrol bombs. And they've got a kind of weird catapult thing on top of these high-rise flats. It's like firing petrol bombs down at the police. One British reporter who was there said, he said, I wasn't really shocked by the hatred of the Catholic residents for the police because I kind of expected that.
RUC在它外面扎营，守着一条前线。在里面，人们建立了紧急急救站。他们有妇女和儿童在接力制造汽油弹。他们在这些高层公寓顶上有一个奇怪的弹弓装置。就像向下向警察发射汽油弹一样。一位在那里的一名英国记者说，他说，我并没有真正被天主教居民对警察的仇恨所震惊，因为我预料到了这一点。
He said, what shocked me was the hatred coming from the RUC, from the police themselves. And I quote, the obscenities, the threats, the religious tauntings, and all coming from a peacekeeping force. But it has to be said, Derry's Protestants don't see it that way. So I mentioned Peter Taylor's book, Loyalist.
他说，让我震惊的是来自RUC，来自警察本身的仇恨。我引用一下，淫秽的话语、威胁、宗教嘲弄，所有这些都来自一支维和部队。但必须说，德里的新教徒并不这么看。所以我提到了彼得·泰勒（Peter Taylor）的书《保皇派》（Loyalist）。
In that book, he's got a quote from a shop assistant who went down to the front line to help the police. And this bloke said, what I saw was an insurrection. I saw groups of people defying law and order, trying to destroy Norris. Northern Ireland and the police were the bulwark against them. They needed all the help they could get. So all day the fighting continues. And then night falls on the 13th. This is a day too,
在那本书里，他引用了一位去前线帮助警察的店员的话。这个家伙说，我看到的是一场起义。我看到一群人无视法律和秩序，试图摧毁北爱尔兰，而警察是抵御他们的堡垒。他们需要他们能得到的所有帮助。所以战斗持续了一整天。然后13日的夜幕降临。这也是一天，
remember, and there's still a stalemate. The RUC is still camped at the entrance to the bogside. There are shops and homes burning. There are clouds of tear gas. And at this point, the Derry Citizens Defence Association issues a public statement and they say we're appealing to every able-bodied man in Ireland to come and help us. Now, every able-putted man in Ireland, of course, there are a lot of people who aren't who live in the Republic of Ireland. And all this time, the government in Dublin has really tried to stay out of this. Remember, they still have this sort of nominal claim to the entire island of Ireland, which they have never really bothered to pursue. All this time, they have issued well-meaning statements defending Catholic interests, but they have kept pretty quiet. But
记住，僵局依然存在。北爱尔兰警察局（RUC）仍然驻扎在博格赛德（Bogside）的入口处。商店和房屋在燃烧。催泪瓦斯弥漫。此时，德里公民保卫协会发表了一份公开声明，他们说我们呼吁爱尔兰每一位身强力壮的男子前来帮助我们。当然，爱尔兰有很多身强力壮的男子并不住在爱尔兰共和国。一直以来，都柏林的政府实际上都在试图置身事外。请记住，他们对整个爱尔兰岛仍有一种名义上的主张，但他们从未真正去追求过。一直以来，他们发表了一些捍卫天主教利益的善意声明，但一直保持相当沉默。但是
that evening, the Taoiseach, Jack Lynch, so he's from Cork, actually. He says, okay, I'm going to have to say something. You know, I have to. And he's quite a mild man of man. You can see the clip online. Lynch goes on Irish TV and he says, we've been watching in horror the scenes in Derry, and this cannot continue. The Parliament of Northern Ireland has clearly lost control and the Irish government can no longer stand by and see innocent people injured and perhaps worse. He says, I'm asking the British to allow UN international peacekeepers to keep the two sides apart. And I've told the Irish army to set up field hospitals along the border so that injured Catholics who don't want to go to Northern Irish hospitals can be treated by our army field hospitals. The Irish army. Right. And as soon as you mentioned, the Irish army, right, that makes things immeasurably worse. because in Northern Ireland the reaction to Lynch's speech
那天晚上，爱尔兰总理杰克·林奇（Jack Lynch）——他其实来自科克——他说，好吧，我必须得说点什么。你知道，我必须得说。他是一个非常温和的人。你可以在网上看到那段视频。林奇在爱尔兰电视台上说，我们一直怀着恐惧的心情注视着德里的场景，这种情况不能再继续下去了。北爱尔兰议会显然已经失去了控制，爱尔兰政府不能再袖手旁观，看着无辜的人受伤，甚至可能发生更糟糕的事情。他说，我请求英国允许联合国国际维和部队将双方隔离开来。我已经告诉爱尔兰军队在边境沿线建立野战医院，这样那些不想去北爱尔兰医院的受伤天主教徒就可以由我们的野战医院进行治疗。爱尔兰军队。没错。而一旦你提到爱尔兰军队，那就会让事情变得不可估量地糟糕，因为在北爱尔兰，对林奇演讲的反应
is like, oh my God, the Irish Army are coming. They're going to get stuck in as well. And loads of people completely wildly don't really pay attention to the details of his remarks, but they just genuinely assume that the Irish Army is about to cross the border and it's really all going to kick off. So in the bog side, people are delighted.
就像是，天哪，爱尔兰军队要来了。他们也要卷进来了。许多人完全没有注意他言论的细节，只是真诚地认为爱尔兰军队即将越过边境，一切都要爆发了。所以在博格赛德，人们很高兴。
They're like, brilliant. Our co-religionists are coming to our aid. But local Protestants in the town and the surrounding villages, they're like, oh my God, the Irish Army are coming. We've got to go and support our police. so they all pile into the streets to support the RUC. You then that evening have a scene of unbelievable chaos.
他们觉得，太棒了。我们的共同信仰者来援助我们了。但镇上和周边村庄的当地新教徒却觉得，天哪，爱尔兰军队要来了。我们必须去支持我们的警察。于是他们全都涌上街头支持北爱尔兰警察局。那天晚上，你看到了一场难以置信的混乱场面。
So the RUC who've been actually fighting the people in the bog side, there's now a third element, which is this great Protestant mob, which breaks through the RUC lines into the bog side. The Catholics then pile into them, massive fighting. One RUC man starts shooting and wounds two people. How many people have died in this? Have anybody died? Nobody has died yet.
所以，一直在与博格赛德民众战斗的北爱尔兰警察局，现在出现了第三个因素，那就是这群庞大的新教暴徒，他们冲破了警察的防线进入了博格赛德。天主教徒随后涌向他们，爆发了大规模的战斗。一名警察开始开枪，打伤了两人。这其中死了多少人？有人死了吗？还没有人死亡。
Meanwhile, that same night, so we're on the 13th. Jack Lynch has made a speech. It's day two. Fighting breaks out in Belfast. People in Belfast have been watching this. And everybody in Belfast now is expecting a similarly apocalyptic showdown in Belfast. So to quote one young loyalist, everybody was involved, the whole community. Basins of water were set out and doors left open for people to run into.
与此同时，就在那天晚上，也就是13号。杰克·林奇发表了演讲。这是第二天。贝尔法斯特爆发了战斗。贝尔法斯特的人们一直在关注这一切。现在贝尔法斯特的每个人都预料到贝尔法斯特也会发生类似的灾难性摊牌。引用一位年轻效忠派的话说，每个人都参与其中，整个社区。人们摆出了水盆，大门敞开，供人们跑进去躲避。
Everybody was bracing themselves. What they believed was going to be a massive attack from their nation. Nationalists on the Falls Road. Of course, the people on the Falls Road are expecting exactly the same thing. They're like, oh, the people on the Shankill Road are about to attack us. So we enter the third day of this, Thursday, the 14th of August. In Derry, the RUC are basically exhausted. They've lost control.
每个人都在严阵以待。他们认为这将是一场来自民族主义者的巨大袭击，地点在福尔斯路（Falls Road）。当然，福尔斯路上的人们预料到的完全一样。他们觉得，哦，尚基尔路（Shankill Road）的人要来攻击我们了。于是我们进入了这场冲突的第三天，8月14日星期四。在德里，北爱尔兰警察局基本上精疲力竭了。他们失去了控制。
They send out a call, mobilize all the B specials. And all these B specials start to assemble outside the bogside with all their weapons, right? They've got makeshift weapons and all this. They're intermingle with crowds of problems. Protestant teenagers and young men and whatnot, getting ready to launch, like, let's go in and take this by force. In Belfast, things are actually, if anything, even worse. It's properly kicked off in Belfast. So there are loyalist gangs roaming the streets. They're throwing petrol bombs into Catholic schools. They're burning down Catholic houses. You know, we're right back in the 1920s, back in 1921 or 22 or something.
他们发出呼吁，动员所有的“B特遣队”（B Specials）。所有这些B特遣队成员开始带着他们的武器在博格赛德外集结，对吧？他们有临时武器和所有这些东西。他们与新教徒人群混在一起。新教青少年和年轻男子等等，准备发动进攻，就像是，我们进去强行夺取这里。在贝尔法斯特，情况实际上甚至更糟。贝尔法斯特的情况确实已经彻底爆发了。有效忠派团伙在街上游荡。他们向天主教学校投掷汽油弹。他们烧毁天主教房屋。你知道，我们又回到了1920年代，回到了1921年或22年左右。
Meanwhile, we've got the first gunfights between the police and the IRA. Remember, the IRA had gone quiet in the 1960s, but they had not. not gone away. And the local IRA commander of Belfast, Liam McMillan, has called up some of his old comrades, says, come on, we've got to go and defend our people. But you asked about guns before. They don't have many guns. They have two submachine guns. They've got a Lee Enfield rifle, and they've got six revolvers. So that's sort of all competing to see who gets the guns. And the fighting becomes concentrated on Divis Street. So when you look at the map, the people are interested, Divis Street is basically the entrance to the Catholic Falls Road area. And there you have
与此同时，我们看到了警察和爱尔兰共和军（IRA）之间的第一次枪战。记住，爱尔兰共和军在1960年代已经沉寂，但他们并没有消失。贝尔法斯特当地的爱尔兰共和军指挥官利亚姆·麦克米伦（Liam McMillan）召集了一些老战友，说，来吧，我们必须去保卫我们的人民。但你之前问过枪支的问题。他们没有多少枪。他们有两把冲锋枪。他们有一支李-恩菲尔德步枪，还有六把左轮手枪。所以大家都在争抢谁能拿到枪。战斗集中在迪维斯街（Divis Street）。所以当你查看地图时，如果人们感兴趣的话，迪维斯街基本上是天主教福尔斯路区域的入口。在那里你有
The IRA firing with these two machine guns and whatnot at loyalists and the police and the RUC are firing back with armoured cars with heavy machine guns on the armored cars. And in all of this kind of chaos, the armored cars start firing into the high-rise flats, the Divis Street flats. And they hit a Catholic schoolboy called Patrick Rooney who was in bed trying to sleep through this. And he was the first child killed in the troubles. He was just nine years old. Actually, the amazing thing is that the casualties aren't even higher. Seven people were killed in total. Two of them shot by the IRA, one by loyalists, and four of them by the security forces.
爱尔兰共和军用这两把机枪等向效忠派和警察开火，而北爱尔兰警察局则用装甲车上的重机枪进行还击。在所有这种混乱中，装甲车开始向高层公寓——迪维斯街公寓开火。他们击中了一名名叫帕特里克·鲁尼（Patrick Rooney）的天主教男学生，他当时正在床上试图在混乱中入睡。他是“动乱”中第一个被杀的孩子。他才九岁。事实上，令人惊讶的是伤亡人数并没有更高。总共有七人死亡。其中两人被爱尔兰共和军射杀，一人被效忠派射杀，四人被安全部队射杀。
Probably 1,000 injured. It's hard to tell because it was often said that Catholics would be less likely to go to hospital. But what's very ominous, of the people injured, more than 100 of them are injured with gunshot wounds. So this is the point where the shooting has really started in earnest. 200 homes are destroyed, probably get just under 2,000 families have to flee their homes and a lot of those end up basically going as refugees across the Irish border. I mean, as melodramatic as it sounds, the Irish government actually established kind of refugee camps on the southern side of the border.
可能有1000人受伤。很难说清楚，因为人们常说天主教徒不太可能去医院。但非常不祥的是，在受伤的人中，有超过100人是枪伤。所以这就是枪击事件真正开始严重起来的时刻。200所房屋被毁，可能有不到2000个家庭不得不逃离家园，其中许多人基本上作为难民越过了爱尔兰边境。我的意思是，尽管听起来很夸张，但爱尔兰政府实际上在边境南侧建立了某种难民营。
Now, in Britain, Harold Wilson and Jim Callaghan, who of course can't have been expected. to do anything about this because they don't know anything about it. They're watching the TV pictures in absolute horror because it's pretty clear at this point that unless something changes, Northern Ireland is going to head for a full-scale kind of civil war. And the pressure to intervene is overwhelming. So the civil rights campaigners,
现在，在英国，哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）和吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callaghan），当然不能指望他们对此做任何事情，因为他们对此一无所知。他们看着电视画面感到无比恐惧，因为此时很明显，除非发生变化，否则北爱尔兰将走向全面的内战。干预的压力是压倒性的。所以民权运动者，
people like John Hume and Jerry Fit, in the last couple of days, have started begging Westminster to send troops. Jerry Fit tells the story that on the 14th of August, he's in Belfast, he's actually taken refuge from the fighting in a bookmakers. That's his excuse anyway. He's in a book is and he says a crowd of Catholic people came in and they were quote screaming and shouting that they were going to be murdered in their
像约翰·休姆（John Hume）和杰里·菲特（Gerry Fitt）这样的人，在过去几天里，已经开始恳求威斯敏斯特派遣军队。杰里·菲特讲述了一个故事，说在8月14日，他在贝尔法斯特，实际上为了躲避战斗，他躲进了一家博彩店。反正这是他的借口。他在博彩店里，他说一群天主教徒冲了进来，他们“尖叫着、喊着”说他们会被杀在床上，并恳求我把军队调进来。他给詹姆斯·卡拉汉打了电话说，我恳求你，吉姆，派军队进来，我永远不会忘记他的回答。杰里，他说，我可以把军队调进来，但要把它撤出来将是一件极其困难的事。这是一个非常好的故事，至于这是否真的发生过，我不知道。但实际上，决定性的请求来自斯托蒙特（Stormont）本身，即北爱尔兰政府。8月14日那天傍晚，詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克（James Chichester Clark）正式要求伦敦派遣军队进入德里的街道。现在，卡拉汉接到电话时正在飞机上。他当时正在回来，几乎令人难以置信的是，他正从锡利群岛（Silly Isles）回来，
beds and begging, begging me to get the army in. And he rang James Callahan and said, I'm pleading with you, Jim, send in the army and I'll never forget his reply. Jerry, he says, I can get the army in, but it's going to be a devil of a job to get it out. It's a very good story whether this actually happened. I don't know. But actually the decisive request comes from Stormont itself from the Northern Ireland government. Late that afternoon, the 14th of August, James Chichester Clark formally asked London to send troops into the streets of Derry. Now Callaghan, when he got the call, was on a plane. He was coming back, almost unbelievably, he was coming back from the Silly Isles,
他去那里会见正在度假、穿着短裤的哈罗德·威尔逊。他从飞机上的领航员那里收到了一张便条，基本上是奇切斯特-克拉克要求你派遣军队，请求派遣军队的许可，卡拉汉在上面潦草地写了一行字并交还给领航员，上面写着“准许”。那天下午5点，约克郡团第一营向博格赛德进军。几乎就在那一刻，各方战斗人员放下武器，
where he'd gone to meet Harold Wilson, who was on holiday in his shorts. And he got a note from the navigator on the plane, basically Chichester Clark, was asking you to send in the troops, permission to send in the troops, and Callahan scribbled a note on it and handed it back to the navigator, the words permission granted. And at 5 o'clock that afternoon, the first battalion of the Yorkshire regiment marched towards the bogside. And almost immediately at that point, the various combatants kind of down tools
撤回了家中等等。第二天下午，即15日，卡拉汉收到了第二个请求。这次是问你能不能也派军队进入贝尔法斯特？到15日夜幕降临时，英国士兵正沿着天主教的福尔斯路行进。这是这个故事中的一个重大时刻。一个重大时刻。我的意思是，我们是在北爱尔兰街头有英国军队的环境下长大的，但这就是这一切开始的时候。还有所有那些检查点和直升机之类的东西。
and retreated back into their homes and whatnot. And the next afternoon, the 15th, Calan got a second request. This time can you send troops into Belfast as well? And by nightfall on the 15th, British soldiers are marching down the Catholic Falls Road. And this is a massive moment in this story. A massive moment. I mean, we grew up with British troops on the streets of Northern Ireland, but this is when it all started. And all those kind of search points and helicopters and things.
派遣军队显然被视为一个错误，一个可怕的错误。但还有什么选择呢？如果他们不被派进去，那么整个事情就会爆炸，变成波斯尼亚之类的。这是60年代美国报纸上常有的一个笑话，
And it is obviously seen as a mistake, a terrible mistake. to send the troops in. But what alternative was there? If they didn't get sent in, then the whole thing just explodes and becomes Bosnia or whatever. It's one of those things that American newspapers in the 60s used to always have this joke
说美国人去爱尔兰度假，在爱尔兰的小路上迷路了，他们摇下车窗，问一个农民之类的人，我怎么从这里去都柏林？那个农民会说，嗯，首先，我不会从这里出发。我想，这就是你会对这个故事所说的，
that Americans have gone holiday to Ireland and they get lost in the lanes of Ireland and they wind down the window, you'd ask a sort of farmer or something, how do I get to Dublin from here? And the farmer would say, well, to start with, I wouldn't start from here. And this is, I think, what you'd say about this story,
当你做出那个决定——我们是否派遣军队时，其实已经太晚了。船已经开走了。你陷入了一个巨大的烂摊子，你无法纠正它。我认为在战斗如此激烈的时候，没有哪种情况，
that by the time when you're making that decision, do we send troops in or not, it's actually too late. The ship has sailed. You're in a massive mess, and you're not going to put it right. I think there is no scenario at this point when the fighting is so bad,
当人们用冲锋枪射击，人们被枪杀，还有装甲车用机枪向塔楼开火时。你不可能不说，派军队。我的意思是，此时任何英国政府都会派遣军队。当然，问题在于他们派出了军队，却完全没有关于如何纠正这一局面的政治策略。解决它的时间应该是10年前，
when people are firing submachine guns and people are being shot and there's like armored cars with machine guns firing into tower blocks. There is no way you're not going to say, send troops. I mean, any British government at this point would have sent the troops. The problem, of course, is they have sent the troops and they have absolutely no political strategy about how they're going to put this right. And the time to fix it would have been 10 years previously,
20年前，而不是现在。当你让它发展到这一步时。这不是很有用的建议，对吧？如果你是……不，这不是有用的建议。我不会从这里出发。建议。是的。所以基本上，尽管随后会发生所有的恐怖事件，他们也必须这样做。如果他们没有这样做，很多人会被杀，每个人都会说，国际上每个人都会说，英国政府的行为是多么令人难以置信的不负责任，他们有这支军队，却不愿用它来保护联合王国的公民。但在这一点上，它被天主教徒视为维和。是的，完全是。我的意思是，这就是这其中的巨大讽刺，对吧？英国军队被派去保护，很大程度上是为了保护
20 years previously, but not now. When you've let it get to this point. That's not very helpful advice, is it? If you're... No, it's not helpful advice. I wouldn't start from here. Advising. Yeah. So basically, they have to do it despite all the horrors that will then follow. they hadn't done it, lots of people would have been killed and everyone would have said, everyone internationally would have said, what an unbelievable act of irresponsibility of the British government, they won't, they have this army, but they won't use it to protect citizens of the United Kingdom. But at this point, it is seen by Catholics as peacekeeping. Yes, totally. I mean, this is the great irony of this, right? The British army was sent in to protect, largely to protect
天主教徒。因为我只是想到了《我与威尔内尔》（Withnail and I），那部著名的电影，背景设定在69年底，威尔内尔在坎布里亚的一家酒吧里假装他在军队服役。是的。他说，我在北爱尔兰服过役。房东说，啊，去打爱尔兰佬（Mick）。是的。但实际上，这在历史上是不准确的，因为在这一点上，人们并不是这样看待它的。这是一个很好的观点。
Catholics. Because I'm just thinking of Withanelle and I, famous film, set in late 69, and with Nail pretends that he's been in the army in a pub in Cumbria. Yes. He said, I've served in Northern Ireland. And the land old says, ah, crack at the Mick. Yes. But actually, that's historically inaccurate, because at this point, that is not how it is being seen. It's a very good point.
它被视为保护天主教徒，确实如此。我的意思是，如果英国军队，几乎，我的意思是，如果政客们对北爱尔兰一无所知，我认为这是一个相当安全的赌注，就像，一大堆18、19、20岁的士兵也不知道。他们根本不知道等待他们的是什么。有一个著名的故事，当他们派遣第一批增援部队时，增援部队被空运到一个机场，然后被用巴士送往贝尔法斯特市中心或他们的军营等等。他们都在一个加油站停下来购买贝尔法斯特的地图，因为他们根本没有地图。
It's seen as protecting the Catholics, exactly so. I mean, if the British troops, almost, I mean, if the politicians don't know anything about Northern Ireland, I think it's a pretty safe bet that, like, a load of 18, 19, 20, or old squatters don't. they have no idea what awaits them. There's this famous story that when they sent the first lot of reinforcements, the reinforcements were flown into an airfield and they were sort of bust into the center of Belfast or to their barracks or whatever. And they all stopped at a petrol station to buy maps of Belfast because they didn't have any maps.
就他们而言，这将是相当容易的。我的意思是，别忘了他们在50年代去过塞浦路斯。他们去过马来亚。他们去过肯尼亚。马来亚，他们击败了一场叛乱，不是吗？当然他们做到了。这是如何击败叛乱的典范。给美国人的一课，
And as far as they're concerned, this is going to be pretty easy. I mean, don't forget they've been in Cyprus in the 50s. They've been in Malaya. They've been in Kenya. Malaya, they had defeated an insurgency. hadn't they? Of course they had. It's the kind of the model of how to defeat an insurgency. A lesson for the Americans of Vienna, which
美国人没有听进去。他们认为，好吧，按照这些标准，这将是相当直接的。据我所知，你知道，可以想象他们互相说。据我所知，那里有一群新教徒，很多天主教徒。新教徒正在踢天主教徒的屁股。我们的工作是进去，告诉他们停止，把他们分开，然后我们就可以回家了。砰，工作完成。
the Americans did not eat. And they think well, by these standards, this is going to be pretty straightforward. As far as I understand you know, can imagine them saying to each other. As far as I understand it, there's a load of Protestants, a lot of Catholics. The Protestants are kicking some bells out. The Catholics. Our job is to go in, tell them to stop, separate them, and then we can all go home. Bang, job done.
起初，他们受到张开双臂的欢迎。我的意思是，你可以看到新闻片段，你可以看到照片，你可以在网上阅读报道。天主教徒对他们大喊，谢谢你们的到来，人们鼓掌欢呼。关于在德里，人们会给他们带炸鱼薯条的故事。你知道，人们会把炸鱼薯条吊到城墙上给他们之类的。彼得·泰勒（Peter Taylor）的书《英国人》（Brits）中，有一段对贝尔法斯特一名士兵的采访引述。我觉得自己像个穿着闪亮盔甲的骑士。孩子们到处跟着你。
And at first, they are welcomed with open arms. I mean, you can see the news footage, you can see photos, you can read the reports online. Catholic shouting at them, thank you for coming, people clapping and cheering them. Stories about in dairy, people would bring them fish and chips. You know, people would kind of winch fish and chips up the city walls to them and stuff. There was a, in Peter Taylor's book, Brits, he has a quotation from an interview with a soldier in Belfast. I felt like a knight in shining armor. Kids were following you everywhere.
有茶、小圆面包和三明治。他们会带着托盘出来。我一定胖了大约一英石（约6.35公斤），这家伙说。你可以看到士兵们靠在装甲车上的照片。他们向孩子们展示他们的枪。他们在和家庭主妇聊天。非常亲密。事实上，太亲密了。老共和党人对此感到震惊。所以后来成为爱尔兰共和军贝尔法斯特指挥官的布伦丹·休斯（Brendan Hughes）说，他说，你知道，我当时很年轻，我记得人们在街角给他们送茶。而我的父亲，他是一个老派的爱尔兰共和军成员，他反对说，我从没想过我会看到这一天，
There were tea and buns and sandwiches. They'd be. you out there with trays. I must have put on about a stone, this guy says. You can see photos of soldiers leaning on their armoured cars. They're showing kids, their guns. They're chatting up housewives. It's very chummy. In fact, so chummy. The old Republicans were shocked by it. So Brendan Hughes, who was later the commander of the IRA in Belfast, said, he said, you know, I was young and I can remember people bringing them tea at the street corners. And my dad, who was an old kind of IRA bloke, and my dad objecting to him saying I never thought I would see the day
你知道，民族主义者、天主教徒会给英国士兵送茶、炸鱼薯条和蛋糕之类的东西。8月底，没过多久，卡拉汉飞往北爱尔兰看看进展如何。他去了德里。
when, you know, nationalists, Catholics would be bringing cups of tea and fish and chips and cakes and stuff to British soldiers. The end of August, so not long afterwards, Callahan flies to Northern Ireland and see how it's all going. And he goes to Derry.
他去了博格赛德。他们已经，你知道，已经有了用白线画出的禁区。他跨过白线进入禁区。没问题。人们，你知道，感谢他。他们为他鼓掌之类的。他们为他欢呼。当他回到伦敦时，报纸说，好吧，詹姆斯·卡拉汉，他曾是一位糟糕的财政大臣，转任内政大臣，这件北爱尔兰事务彻底重建了他的声誉。他是当之无愧的人物。英国的果断和冷静占了上风。但实际上在这次旅行中，卡拉汉，因为他不是白痴，他注意到他从天主教徒那里得到了很多微笑，但他没有从联合派那里得到多少微笑。许多强硬派一点也不高兴。
He goes to the bog side. They've already, you know, there are already no-go areas that are painted with white lines. And he steps over the white lines to go into the no-go areas. And it's fine. People, you know, thank him. They clap him and stuff. They cheer him. And when he gets back to London, the papers say, well, James Callahan, who'd been a terrible chancellor and had moved to him secretary, this Northern Ireland business has completely rebuilt his reputation. It's the man of the hour. British decisiveness and son foie have prevailed. But actually on this trip, Callaghan, because he's not an idiot, he notices that he's getting a lot of smiles from the Catholics, but he's not getting many smiles from the Unionists. And a lot of the hardliners are really not happy at all.
正如其中一人后来所说，感觉就像我们被自己的军队入侵了一样。他和伊恩·佩斯利（Ian Paisley）有一次令人难以置信的交流。卡拉汉，他是一名浸信会教徒，对伊恩·佩斯利说，你知道，佩斯利博士，我们都是上帝的孩子。汤姆，伊恩·佩斯利说了什么？不，我们不是，卡拉汉先生。我们是愤怒之子。是的。我想在某种程度上佩斯利是对的。
As one of them said later, it felt as if we were being invaded by our own army. And he has this incredible exchange with Ian Paisley. Callaghan, who was a Baptist, said to Ian Paisley, you know, Dr. Paisley, we're all the children of God. And Tom, what does Ian Paisley say? No, we are not, Mr. Callahan. We are the children of Roth. Yeah. And I guess at some level Paisley is right.
因为在这一点上，1969年8月，他们确实是愤怒之子。现在回头可能太晚了。有太多的不信任。有太多的对抗。有太多的暴力。我认为这一点可能没有得到应有的重视。因为在某种和平协议之后，在某种程度上有一种轻微的遗忘文化，顺便说一句，这在政治上是完全可以理解的。
Because at this point, August 1969, they are the children of Roth. It is too late probably to turn back. There is too much distrust. There's too much antagonism. There's too much violence. And I think a point that's probably not brought out as often as it should be. Because in the wake of the sort of peace agreement, there's to some degree a slight culture of forgetting, which is completely understandable, by the way, politically.
但我认为被低估的是，一切出错的事情，很大程度上是那些积极希望看到事情变得更糟的人所意愿的，因为这符合他们的政治利益。所以那些想看到战斗、纵容杀戮和升级以及所有这些的人。所以想与“内部敌人”摊牌的效忠派，想看到暴力升级的共和党人，因为他们想让人们反对英国。他们想要一个统一的爱尔兰。我一直认为明显的相似之处是1990年代南斯拉夫的战争。所以，在1994年左右的波斯尼亚，人们会说，好吧，这都是古代仇恨的结果。没有人能对此做些什么。或者他们会说，好吧，实际上，它只是由几个恶毒、可怕的人指挥的，他们引导，你知道，引导他们的选民走上了混乱和仇恨的道路，所有
But I think what's underestimated is how much, everything that goes wrong, a lot of it is willed by people who actively wanted to see things get worse because they would suit their political interests. So people who wanted to see fighting and who connived at killing and escalation and all of this. So loyalists who wanted a showdown with the sort of the enemy within, Republicans who wanted to see the violence escalate because they wanted to do. turn people against the British. They wanted to get a united Ireland. I always think that the obvious parallel is the wars in Yugoslavia in the 1990s. So in, you know, 1994 or something in Bosnia, people would say, well, this is all the result of ancient hatreds. There's nothing anyone can do about it. Or they would say, well, actually, it's just being directed by a few malevolent, monstrous people who've led, you know, led their voters sort of down the road of chaos and hatred and all
这些。而事实上，真相是，这是两件不同事情的相互作用。这是背景的相互作用，即怀疑和冲突的历史，这是无法消除的，但也是个人决策者的相互作用。我们已经看到了他们，你知道，伊恩·佩斯利或任何人，或者组织游行的人，或者故意试图挑起暴力的人，或者拿起枪的人，那些为了在他们看来似乎是理性的政治原因，有意识地决定选择升级和紧张局势，而不是他们所说的绥靖政策的人。而且实际上，在这一点上，即69年夏末，已经有很多人，主要是贝尔法斯特和德里的年轻人，他们说，好吧，那是
of this. And actually, the truth is, it's the interplay of two different things. It's the interplay of the context, the history of suspicion and conflict, which can't be wished away, but also individual decision makers. We've seen them in already, you know, Ian Paisley or whoever, or the people who organise the marches, or the people who deliberately try to provoke violence, or the people who pick up their guns, people who, for what perhaps seem to them rational, political reasons, they consciously decide to choose escalation and tension rather than, as they would call it, appeasement. And already, actually, at this point, so in late summer of 69, there are lots of people, young men largely in Belfast and Derry, who are saying, okay, well, that was
第一回合，但第二回合很快就会到来。国家不会保护我们。我们需要保护自己。我们需要枪。我们需要做好准备。而且，你知道，当下次枪声响起时，我们将，你知道，我们不会胡闹。而且，他们不需要等太久。因为在10月10日，英国政府发布了一份关于近期骚乱的报告。疯狂的是，这份报告是由约翰·亨特爵士（Sir John Hunt）撰写的，
round one, but round two is coming very soon. The state won't protect us. We need to protect ourselves. We need guns. We need to get ready. And, you know, when the shooting starts next time, we will be you know, we're not going to mess around. And the fact, they don't have long to wait. Because on the 10th of October, the British government published a report on the recent disorder. And insanely, this report was written by Sir John Hunt,
那个在1953年领导征服珠穆朗玛峰探险队的人。并不是因为他是一位伟大的登山家才给了他专业知识。他也是英国陆军的一员。他的建议是，军队应该从北爱尔兰警察局手中接管军事治安，并让我们解散B特遣队。天主教徒恨他们。他们视他们为压迫工具，除掉他们。这引发了
the man who had led the expedition to conquer Everest in 1953. It wasn't the fact that he was a great mountaineer that gave him the expertise. He was also in the British Army. His recommendations were, the army should take over kind of military policing from the RUS and led us disband the be specials. The Catholics hate them. They see them as a tool of oppression, get rid. And this sets off
为期三天的尚基尔路新教徒骚乱。你看到了暴徒攻击英国军队同时挥舞联合杰克旗的非凡景象。你知道，我们是英国对抗你们的捍卫者。高潮出现在11日晚上，2000人游行到迪维斯街这些由英国军队防线守卫的高层公寓。这是一场激烈的战斗，石头、汽油弹、催泪瓦斯，老一套。有人在混乱中开始射击，军队开始还击。66人受伤，其中21人是士兵。两名当地男子，乔治·迪基（George Dickey）和赫伯特·豪（Herbert Howe），他们都是新教徒，被英国军队枪杀，还有一名29岁的年轻北爱尔兰警察维克多·阿巴克尔（Victor Arbuckle）也被杀。他已婚，有两个非常小的
three days of rioting in the Protestant Shankill Road. You have these extraordinary spectacle of mobs attacking British troops while waving the Union Jack. You know, we are the defenders of Britain against you. And the climax comes on the night of the 11th, 2,000 people marching on these high-rise flats on Divers Street, which have been guarded by lines of British troops. It's a pitch battle, stones, petrol bombs, tear gas, the usual. Somebody starts shooting in the chaos and the troops start shooting back. Sixty-six people are injured, 21 of them soldiers. Two local men, George Dickey and Herbert Howe, who were both Protestants, are shot dead by the British Army and also killed is a young RUC constable called Victor Arbuckle, who's 29. He was married with two very small
孩子，一个男孩和一个女孩，他被一名狙击手杀害，讽刺的是，不是来自爱尔兰共和军，而是来自阿尔斯特志愿军（Ulster Volunteer Force）。他是“动乱”中第一个被杀的北爱尔兰警察，但他绝不是最后一个。不，远非如此。所以下次我们将进入1970年代，北爱尔兰将有效地螺旋式上升为内战。所以在下一集中，临时爱尔兰共和军将进入故事。英国军队将遭受第一次伤亡。爆炸事件将恶化。而我们1974年系列节目的英雄泰德·希思（Ted Heath）将加入聊天。
children, a boy and a girl, and he was killed, ironically, by a sniper, not from the IRA, but from the Ulster volunteer force. He was the first Northern Irish policeman to be killed in the troubles, but he was not, alas, the last. No, far from it. So next time we will be heading into the 1970s and Northern Ireland will be spiraling towards effectively a civil war. So in the next episode, the provisional IRA will be entering the story. The British Army will be taking its first casualties. The bombings will worsen. And Ted Heath, hero of our series on 1974, enters the chat.
人们会惊讶地听到泰德·希思的政府正准备进行一场真正灾难性的赌博。那样的几率是多少？然后在我们的最后一集，动乱的血腥之年，也就是1972年，德里的血腥星期日，贝尔法斯特的血腥星期五，以及最后一次和平的机会。所以俱乐部会员当然现在就可以听到那两集。如果你不是会员，你可以在therestisistory.com加入他们。会员还会收到我们精彩的时事通讯，里面充满了令人惊叹的专题、测验、竞赛，简直是难以置信的价值。
And people will be stunned to hear that Ted Heath's government is preparing to take a truly disastrous gamble. What are the odds on that? And then in our final episode, the bloody steer of the troubles, which is 1972, Bloody Sunday in Derry, Bloody Friday in Belfast, and one last chance for peace. So club members, of course, can hear those two episodes right now. And if you're not a member, you can join them on the rest is history.com. And members also receive our brilliant newsletter full of amazing features, quizzes, competitions, just unbelievable value.
历史学家的文章。历史学家的文章。谁不喜欢历史学家的文章呢？我知道我喜欢历史学家的文章。你当然喜欢。谢谢大家的收听。谢谢，多米尼克。再见。
Essays by historians. Essays by historians. Who doesn't love an essay by a historian? I know I love an essay by historian. Of course you do. Thank you everyone for listening. Thanks, Dominic. Bye-bye.
再见。嗨，大家好，又是多米尼克。现在，这是我们承诺给你们的来自我们的节目《读书俱乐部》的片段，谈论欧内斯特·海明威的书《丧钟为谁而鸣》，特别是西班牙内战的历史。
Bye-bye. Hi, everybody, Dominic again. Now, here is the clip that we promised to you from our show The Book Club, which talks about Ernest Hemingway's book for whom the bell tolls and specifically the history of the Spanish Civil War.
所以西班牙根本没有参与第一次世界大战。它一直是一个落后地区。基本上，它在政治上非常动荡。有一个国王。通常是议会制。西班牙大部分地区没有受到现代世界的影响。所以它感觉就像这些被称为“大庄园”（Latifundiae）的巨大地产，可以追溯到罗马时期。我发现这太不可思议了。在开始为第二部分阅读之前，我一无所知。好吧，这实际上适用于西班牙和葡萄牙。他们会有绝对巨大的农村
So Spain has not been involved in the First World War at all. It's been a backwater. Basically, it's been really politically turbulent. There is a king. It's normally a parliamentary system. Most of Spain is untouched by the modern world. So it feels like these these huge estates called the Latifundiae, which go back to the Roman period. I found this extraordinary. I had no idea until I started reading up for the second. Well, this is true of Spain and Portugal, actually. They would have absolutely gigantic rural
由土地所有者经营的庄园，几乎回到了封建制度。农民被土地所有者和教会等所束缚。西班牙有部分地区已经工业化，巴斯克地区、北部和加泰罗尼亚，但那些显然是有分裂主义运动的地方。所以西班牙感觉非常分裂，有很多劳工动荡，有一个大的无政府主义运动，有一个社会主义运动，有一个共产党。在20年代，发生了一场政变，一位将军在国王之下夺取了权力，名叫米格尔·普里莫·德里维拉（General Miguel Primo de Rivera）。但这并没有真正奏效。
estate run by landowners, almost going to feudal system. The peasants are enthralled to the landowner and to the church and whatnot. There are parts of Spain that have industrialized, the Basque Country, the North and Catalonia, but those are obviously places with separatist movements. So Spain feels very fractured, and there's lots of labour unrest, there's a big anarchist movement, there was a socialist movement, there was a communist party. In the 20s, there was a coup and a general took power called General Miguel Primo de Rivera, under the king. But that didn't really work out.
他们在1930年代初恢复了民主，但在右翼和左翼之间极其两极分化和不稳定。有可怕的罢工。例如，在1935年的北部，有暗杀事件，有某种准军事运动等等。前独裁者普里莫·德里维拉的儿子建立了一个名为“长枪党”（Falange）的小法西斯政党，这实际上给了它名字，真的，它后来被右翼、被赢得西班牙内战的保守派所收编。我的意思是，他们是否真的是法西斯分子，或者他们是否只是基本上在使用法西斯标签，这是一个有趣的问题。好吧，所以这一切在1936年达到了顶峰。年初举行了一次选举，
They brought back democracy at the beginning of the 1930s, but it's incredibly polarized and unstable between right and left. There are terrible strikes. So, for example, in the north in 1935, there are assassinations, there are kind of paramilitary movements and whatnot. The son of the previous dictator, Primo de Rivera, sets up a little fascist party called the Falange, which actually sort of gives its name, really, to, it's then co-opted by the right, by the conservatives who win the Spanish Civil War. I mean, whether they're really fascists or whether they're just basically using the fascist label is an interesting question. Right, so it all comes to our head in 1936. There's an election at the beginning of the year,
这意味着一个“人民阵线”（Popular Front），这是一种左翼联盟。由自由派、社会主义者、你知道，某种左翼政党、一些分裂主义者或来自巴斯克地区或加泰罗尼亚等地区的更多民族主义团体组成，他们上台了。并且有很多社会动荡，因为他们想推动激进的变革，而右翼不喜欢那样。1936年7月，军队发动了，
which means that a popular front, which is a kind of left-wing alliance. of liberals, socialists, you know, sort of left-wing parties, some of the separatists, or more nationalist groups from the areas like the Basque Country or Catalonia, they come to power. And there's a lot of social unrest because they want to push through radical changes and the right don't like that. And in July 1936, the army launches,
军队内部的右翼分子发动了政变。西班牙内战发生的原因是政变并没有完全奏效。所以基本上，工会、马德里、巴塞罗那等大城市仍然忠于民选政府。因此，西班牙分裂为叛军、军队中的政变者及其盟友（通常是大土地所有者、天主教会等，他们想捍卫现状）。他们占领了半个国家，通常是农村地区，更保守等等。
right-wing elements within the army launch a coup. The reason the Spanish Civil War happens is the coup doesn't fully work. So basically, trade unions, the big cities in Madrid, Barcelona and so on, stay loyal to the elected government. So Spain is divided between the rebels, the coup people in the army, and their allies who are often like big landowners, the Catholic Church and so on, who want to defend the status quo. They've got half the country, often kind of rural areas, more conservative and so on.
但大城市和加泰罗尼亚等等，所以，马德里、巴塞罗那之类的地方，他们仍然忠于民选政府。所以一方面，你有所谓的“民族主义者”，这些是右翼势力、军队、政变策划者等等。实际上，从第一天起，他们就得到了来自意大利墨索里尼和后来德国希特勒的非常非常强大的国际支持。然后在左翼，你有民选政府，他们是“共和派”，他们最终得到了苏联的帮助，这是一种毒酒。他们确实向英国和法国寻求帮助，但他们并没有真正得到。他们得到了外国志愿者的帮助。这场战争变得极其痛苦和极其血腥。
But the big cities and Catalonia and so on, so on, so, Madrid, Barcelona, places like that, they stay loyal to the elected government. So on the one hand, you have what are called the nationalists, and these are the forces of the right, the army, the coup-plotters and so on. Effectively, from day one, they have very, very strong international backing from Mussolini in Italy and then Hitler in Germany. And then on the left, you have the elected government, who are the Republicans, and they get help eventually from the Soviet Union, which is something of a poison chalice. And they do appeal to Britain and France for help, but they don't really get it. And they have help from foreign volunteers. And this war becomes incredibly bitter and incredibly bloody.
我的意思是，内战总是这样，因为人们觉得这是一场生存斗争，他们国家的未来岌岌可危。他们开始相信，你知道，他们的邻居、隔壁镇的人、土地所有者或牧师、或无政府主义者或任何人，都要杀死他们和他们的家人，所以我们必须先杀死他们。人们，在某些地方，有可怕的、可怕的、虐待狂的大屠杀之类的事情。
I mean, this is always the way with civil wars, because people feel it's an existential struggle, the future of their country is at stake. They come to believe, you know, their neighbors, the people in the next town, the landowners or the priests, or the anarchists or whoever, are going to kill them in their families, so we've got to kill them first. People, in some places, there are horrendous, horrendous, sadistic massacres and things.
我想他们在21世纪初左右发现，西班牙在柬埔寨之后拥有最高数量的乱葬坑。所以如果你想听完整的一集，只需去Apple、Spotify或YouTube搜索《读书俱乐部》。就是这样。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
I think they found something like at the end of, maybe the start of the 21st century or something, that Spain had the highest number of mass graves after Cambodia. So if you want to hear the full episode, just go to Apple or Spotify or YouTube and search for The Book Club. And there it is. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我想他们大概是在21世纪初左右发现，西班牙的乱葬岗数量仅次于柬埔寨。如果你想收听完整节目，请前往Apple、Spotify或YouTube搜索“The Book Club”。就是这样。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击逐字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。